le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par police lit police la compagnie
québécoise qui offre les matelas
d'occupation double cette année
donc si vous voulez dormir aussi bien
que les candidats dans la maison mixte
commandé un police libre et au delà
reposer en alliant bulletin sympa qui
donne bien botté nzoto un beau ricky le
nôtre ami renaud pour ceux qui
l'écoutent pas si on donne notre bon ami
renault avec qui on joue ici même à
dorian dragon est maintenant à
occupation double alors on encourage à
la maison mix à dormir sur des polices
lie depuis jamais eu l'air aussi fluide
l'air bien reposé j'ai jamais vu
rayonner comme ça donc un code promo
pour les produits police l'ipb
d'ailleurs nous mêmes on utilise les
polices les plaidoyers moi je dors là
dessus depuis un bon bout de temps et je
dors très bien j'ai pas mal dans le coup
et c'est parfait est ce que j'ai une
gueule un code promo cs100 filtre s25 ça
vous donne 25 % de rabais sur tous les
produits police l'ip matelas oreillers
extérieur tous sauf les semis exact que
le code promo est valide en fait
jusqu'au 12 octobre donc s sans filtre s
25 en un mot merci à paul islip pilleurs
ciao production du f bienvenue au sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités date cette
super content avec moi dôme plantes
je tenterai sans moldus prod cas ce
qu'on vient d'enregistrer vous pouvez
nous suivre sur peut tuer on en parle et
on vient d'enregistrer en fait le encore
moins de filtres donc un petit show est
ce que deux mois et demi quand on parle
du podcast qui ont été enregistrés s'il
voulait en entendre plus à l'est le lien
vers le pétrole mais sans plus attendre
omagad quand même pauvre on à me parlait
beaucoup
ph daniel bélanger et est sur notre
liste depuis le début c'est un une
grande inspiration et grandes idoles
pour nous on aime vraiment beaucoup ce
qui fait peut être incomplète honneur de
le recevoir ici qui parle avec lui ont
eu du fun on a ri hydroliés relaxe est
fin et généreux y pertinent est
intelligent et philosophe lis tous ces
qualificatifs le même temps c'était
vraiment un grand plaisir on a abordé
plein de sujets sa carrière tout le pré
son processus de création tous ses
albums s'est tournée des histoires de
tourner avec ses musiciens à la faune de
parler il travaille comme préposée
bénéficiaire est revenue là dessus
commence à le marquer comme influence et
sa musique
comment il écrit ses chansons est
vraiment passionnant c'est le fun
d'avoir accès à un artiste aussi
mythique quelqu'un aussi qu'on entend
rarement parler en fait de tous ces
sujets lors qu'ils plutôt discret dans
les médias en général dont on a parlé
pendant plus de deux heures
on a appris plus sur la personne sur
commun qui travaillent sur surtout ceux
c'était vraiment un grand privilège pour
nous on est super content - un podcast
légendaire quittant qui l'est tout
autant laisser des commentaires
participer à discussion on aime ça vous
lire
cet homme n'a pas bonne et vos chances
vous connaissez comment ça se passe mais
surtout parlez-en à vos proches par
exemple vos amis et sans plus attendre
bon podcast daniel bélanger bonne écoute
[Musique]
merci énormément merci de lévitation
on est vraiment content en fin de
rencontre mais il s'est beaucoup je me
demande et parce que tu es tu es quand
même quelqu'un de plutôt discret en
général un homme de plus de mon match ou
un baptême et ont publiquement dans ta
vie oui je sens qu'elle met bien merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation pis je me
demande également pourquoi les questions
2 je cherche des moyens alternatifs de
rejoindre les gens puis les podcasts ça
c'est tout à fait ce que cherche puis
avec des personnes intelligentes comme
vous deux je vous ai entendu faire une
entrevue avec juliette
et puis ça me semble vraiment plus et
puis voilà je dis pas qu'elle est liée
pas les autres moyens sont les personnes
sont prêtes elles jantes je ne cherche
cherche à renouveler la façon de
rejoindre les gens en dehors des les
résout mais nous sommes contre ce jour
oui mais qu'est ce qui motive ce désir
là d'essayer de trouver des méthodes
alternatives
l'ennui c'est à dire que oui parce qu'il
ya des fois c'est que je vois je vois
ces moyens-là du podcast de de parler du
métier peut-être plus parler des
affaires qui m'intéresse moi manquerait
de parler a été un peu plus people
pendant 10 minutes
l'oeil l'album puis on remarque que
j'aime la radio 1 c'est donc qu'il
podcasts les proches de radio mais comme
des télé ça ça fait des bus depuis que
j'ai commencé à présenter mon travail
que la télé il faut être en tout cas
dans mon cas il faut être un sprinteur
il faut que ce capot long puisque tu as
tout dit puisqu'il est resté
[Musique]
sympathique où un bon point chez
rapidement huawei pour scorer en parlons
il y en a qui sont très très bon pied
moi je sais jamais si ça ça aussi ça se
propage alors que l'or avec je sais pas
combien de temps on va discuter autant
qu'on aura à dire mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est plus relax
ça ressemble plus à l'abri ouais c'est
vrai que c'est rare qu'on entend les
artistes se mettront vraiment parler de
l'acte ii the throne l'album le pti
jamais jamais jamais si je fais de la
promo c'est toujours celle issue tv oui
c'est pas des mois studio à travailler
ton sens à peu près des mois en parler
en entrevue que j'essaye d'avoir ce pas
tous avoir semblé plus à nos discussions
avec une bière puis au bac est mythique
[Rires]
c'est là je peux dire c'est probablement
ce qu'on en fait c'est un peu surréel on
dirait de t'avoir devant moi parce que
pour notre génération
j'ai 29 ans oui et j'ai jamais connu un
monde aussi que daniel bélanger t'es pas
dans le paysage ouais mais pas
médiatique mais artistique au québec
tant que quand je suis maintenant 91
fake rapidement la musique qui jouait
quand je prenais conscience tu es tu es
deux premiers albums
ce qui m'intéressait plus à la musique
c'est à rêver mieux qu'ils sortaient
bouille a jamais eu un un monde où
est-ce que
j'étais pas de quoi cette épaule et est
ce que est ce que tu vu un peu dans ton
nom ton parcours
le public se rajeunir devant toi parce
que ceux qui consommaient ton mes
parents le kiki qui ont acheté des
albums au moment où il sortait vraiment
et très pas encore tout autant suivre et
que d'autre part le mans qui se présente
encore devant toi mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya plusieurs trucs là dessus c'est
à dire que moi quand j'avais 10 ans
j'écoutais pas la même musique que mes
parents donc que vous allez vous avez
probablement écouter rêver mieux dans
une voiture avec beau parent oui je suis
pauvre et des bonnes chances
cessons donc et aujourd'hui c'est
georges sur un coin de rue puis à des
gens qui passent je fais mon furent
oubliés des gens qui passent devant moi
plein un père avec son fils sont
vraiment billet paris ils sont habillés
pareil comme le père et le fils est
habillé pareil en 48 sauf que c'était le
petit gars qui est habillé comme le père
placé au jeu reims et le père kyo comme
son office
ok donc et puis il ya des bonnes chances
qu'elle paraît le fils écoute la musique
petit trip qu'ils se fassent kucher
voies détournées côte sud
je pense le décalage est possible que le
décalage était avec mes parents ma mère
allait mais bing crosby faux frank
sinatra que j'ai appris à apprécier les
deux plus tard mais sur le coup c'est
parce que tu écoutes mans écoute les dix
plein pic atteint donc y assure you
aussi que y est arrivé un drôle de
phénomène avec rêver mieux c'est la
chanson dans un spoutnik i c'était très
attirant pour un enfant
7ce musique lui la musique y avait des
gadgets donnant le vidéo ici était très
le titre aussi cet effet oui qu'est ce
que c'est ça et donc il y avait je pense
que c'était attirant pour l'enfant
d'écouté dans un spot nick donc rêver
murette ses larges
l'italie rejoint de beaucoup beaucoup de
monde
et ce qui fait que dans mes salles d'un
panda rêver mieux donc les mes deux
premiers albums j'avais des gens plutôt
jeune rêver mieux c'était encore des
gens plutôt jeune homme avec des enfants
et après ça il ya eu l'échec du matériel
qui était quand même
il y en avait qui attendaient rêver
mieux 2 et le moi je suis arrivé avec
l'opposition pas très joyeux par rapport
à rêver mieux
et après ça je suis arrivé avec
nous mais aussi à chic de ville qui est
arrivé avec kids country complètement
j'ai fait des tournées oui je voyais des
gens sortir de la salle de bain pendant
mes chansons c'est que ce que je
respecte totalement
c'est sûr que si tu cites a pas écouté
beaucoup l'album tu t'attends à voir
avoir rêvé mieux parce que tu n'en il y
en a qui attendent toujours rêver mieux
le québec areq mais bon ça arrivera
peut-être un jour il veut rêver mieux 2
est donc là avec chic de ville me suis
éloigné un peu de 2 des racines ouais
mais il y avait un noyau dur qui venait
tester ou kiki je me rattache ya eu un
spectacle parce qu'ils étaient très
enthousiasmés et quand je suis arrivé
avec halo moment c'est comme si c'était
pour tout le monde est heureux tout
voilà à ce que je faisais un autre le
s'habitue helmand donc là j'en avais
juste vraiment 8 heures 8 à 88 ce qui
causait des skins cause parfois des
soucis de un souci de en spectacle juste
à l'ue et au fmi et la joue et le jeu ya
beaucoup beaucoup de monde tous les âges
donc mon adresse le ya quelqu'un qui les
hauteurs de la ville haute à l'autre qui
est un peuple qui crie vieux qui sèche
j'ai pas une culture de spectacles de
l'enquêté il y en a qui sont bons chez
ceux qui sont à l'écouté des charles
aznavour me tombent des murs et des
concerts formule concert on y côtoie
plus étalé les autres fous qui y qui
s'en sortir
j'avais tout le monde dont ce qui fait
que ça fait le cerveau des foyers tout
en nous comment comment rallier tout le
monde et puis par la magie de ce poids
de la musique à la fin tout le monde est
ensemble mais au début quand tu fais ton
spectacle où est fermée puis que tout de
tout le registre de ce qu'est mon
travail ça ça c'est curieux c'est pas
comme si j'étais donc pure et dure
j'aurais juste des banques pourront
comparer banques
et on chanterait pontes du milieu pions
dans ce raid
c'est ma plaie pour ce lundi 1 h et
c'est un compliment pour moi de voir
toutes sortes de gens qui aiment
toujours de musique
mais justement si j'apparais approche
quant aux autres et puis juste un petit
teaser sur les réseaux sociaux type
comme de quoi qu on en est les
sauveteurs se voir depuis le nombre de
messages que j'ai su de gens de ma
génération tcc c'est plus que que j'aime
reçu le message
ok mais c'est vraiment j'ai l'impression
pitié je pense pas que ça aurait été le
même
la même excitation de d'autres artistes
de sa génération senti chez les jeunes
filles vraiment un engouement puis
vraiment il ya vraiment une appréciation
qui énorme encore chez les jeunes pitt
et fait mouche à la musique petit mes
amies musiciennes d'amis auteur
compositeur autour de moi des berges est
toujours cité comme une influence
oui je retiens encore aujourd'hui cia
puis qui même à l écoute des albums t il
aligné au chômage mais je voudrais tous
écoutés mais je l'espère sera passée
pour 1000 hors frais dans ma mémoire
tpiy ce musée qui vieillit vraiment bien
je trouve ce musique tzigane l'entendre
dire parce que moi je suis très mal
placé moi je sais moi je donc je peux je
me lève pas le matin brian bélanger qui
vient quand même de se lever
[Rires]
l'instinct guerrier des temps si je
regarde dans le miroir
c'est la fin donc j'ai pas vraiment
quelqu'un qui essaye comme tout le monde
de s'en sortir est calculable le matin
et donc j'ai de la difficulté à avoir
lorgné - difficulté à voir si mes albums
vieillissent bien au port je suis mal
placé premièrement parce que j'ai de la
difficulté à écouter mais mes albums
précédents pas que je lire ni voyez
c'est juste que je relaxe pas quand j'ai
toujours mon dieu qu à personne mais je
me calme mais aussi je me dis bon c'est
ce que je voulais faire à l'époque et
tout ça pique comme j'ai toujours essayé
de travailler être sûrement x
complètement quand je suis qu'en ces
temps de le faire et puis je suis
paresseux
des fois je m'endorme fessenheim qui l'a
jamais jeu désormais non le fallait
comme vous je suis battu mais je suis
comme tout le monde je veux des fois et
est une idée de la boisson sur l'album
tu veux tu veux que l'album sorte de
toile monette et été commis ouais enfin
que voilà pour savoir si ça vieillit
bien aussi ça vieillit mal
je trouve que le premier a commencé
quand même avoir fait neuf mois que
d'autres voudraient c'est vieux mais ce
qui vieillit bien c'est l'hiver dans le
fond les lecteurs sèche les guitares
électriques de 400 vols des hommes
probablement qui vieillit peut-être un
petit peu un petit peu moins vite et
beaucoup de rock maintenant pascal bloch
dura que cinq ans par hervé oui est-ce
que c'est dans l'espèce de parcours de
d'album en album
ou est-ce qu'il ya toujours une
recherche de
ne pas du moins à toi collège-lycée non
plus mais d'essayer de ne pas reproduire
l'album précédent et puis nous on en
parle quand même souvent de ces deux
groupes qui des groupes de musique qu'on
écoute d'auteur composants est un prêtre
qui après deux ou trois à faire la même
chose a amené sa séance et sauf il ya
plus besoin non plus d'une autre tous
deux se dit c'est ça les chansons puis
ça est ce que pour toi c'est un souci
avec un nouvel album qui ont eu la
chance d'écouter qui instrumente air est
complètement qui voit complètement
ailleurs
est ce que c'est un souci pour toi de
continuer à renouveler
ton nom mais il ya un mois sa main
sécurisé de me répéter il y en a que
sally sall et sécurisé 15 à baisser mon
créneau où je veux pas sortir de l'eau
il faut dire aussi qu'il ya des aspects
financiers mon premier album un marché
forme un tournant marché feu fort aussi
ce qui fait que j'ai des réserves
pourrait pour réfléchir puis pour être
un peu dépendant mais il ne sait pas
tout le monde que la pas tout le monde
qui est qui cette possibilité là de
mesures en ce sens il faut et donc moi
ça me sam sécurisé est de faire autre
chose ça pour moi je me disais ça brille
les gens ont peut-être trouvé ça dur les
premières fois je n'étais pas si
conscient que c'est parce que chaque
fois que sur l'album tu te demandes si
c'est la fin t'es où
maintenant le ccc three comme ça c'est
un truc d'humeur les gens et il salue en
plus aux poudres je sais pas l'argentin
fait que nous non s'il vend à tourner
bizarrement et coutts a encore des liens
de bélanger ça se peut
et puis je l'accepté moi j'étais comme
ça avec des
des gens que j'aime et puis ça marche
plus je me suis un fan mais je suis
consciente donc peut-être pour ça je me
forçais encore plus pour je me bats pour
rester pour rester vivants
artistiquement puis essayer de rester
curieux monde ici pas de rester jeunes
cdh rester curieux de venir jour j'ai
fait une entrevue à radio-canada le
matin puis révèle me demander comment on
fait pour rester jeunes pij est jugé
comme un après coup je me suis remis
dans le panneau avec le reste est jeune
c'est pas rester jeune je vieillis j'ai
58 ans ça ne marchera pas rester jeune
il faut rester curieux garder des
valeurs de la valeur de la jeunesse
c'est juste la curiosité faut juste
garder le lephone la curiosité depuis
dans le monde dans lequel on vit malgré
toutes ces difficultés pcc confinement
pcc truc je trouvais sont trouvés sont
qui dans la main donc si je vous dis
aussi que j'avais 30 ans quand le
premier album a fonctionné ça que
j'avais vu neiger j'avais zappé le fait
toutes sortes de job avant alors quand
ça s'est mis en marche et je me suis dit
faut que je prenne soin de faux je
respecte parce que je suis bien ici là
demain donc j'essaie de travailler ou de
travailler beaucoup il ya beaucoup
d'inspiration mais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup travail de deux mois
le quotidien oui oui c'est travailler
tout juste réfléchit pas s'attacher à ce
qu'on vient de faire il faut faire trois
textes la même chanson le fait à
condamner une heure plus tard consent
pas à l'intérieur que s'il ya plus rien
qui cloche avec le tiens on
intellectualiste pas tout quand on fait
une chanson je suis offert une chanson
puis je veux faire du déni
zaki un couplet sur les sabres alors
c'est bon hemani plus le temps passe
plus je tends n'auriez pas car aix était
couplée au pire mais c'est vrai que je
pense de moi qui t'ai maniche j'allume
puis choisit mais mon dieu ça va prendre
beaucoup de plaisir à faire le couple
est au pis ça va prendre juste trois
quatre jours une semaine ou plus cinq
minutes c'est juste c'est comme une
espèce de l'apport de la peur on l'a on
avait trouvé de quoi le sait que la peur
de se retrouver que je ne sais pas si
conscient que ça mais c'est un peu comme
ce paquet globe et tu te rends compte
que tout est possible que tu peux
changer tout n'importe quand si on te
donne le temps de le faire indique
moment les boules mais j'aime et
impressions assorties telle date tel
date toujours baisse c'est pas prêt on
reporte europe
ok ça c'est précieux je deviens est une
malédiction un certain point de vouloir
tout changer c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont
de l'atonie fini pisser boulet ça se
peut que ça se peut que tu as pourri ça
finisse par se trompent
ouais elle même puis de perdre le
leadership du début ouais mais s'ajuste
avec l'expérience pour que s'y
reconnaître là que non le la tour
n'avait pu s'ils changent encore quelque
chose de jeu a beau rester là je vais
travailler sur autre chose des fois tu
travailles aussi des fois ce stade c'est
pas cette affaire une chanson que c'est
alice de côté qui soit en faire deux
autres meilleurs que ça alors que c'est
un truc très
édenté dans le noir mais puis a pas de
recette non plus tu as tant que ça parce
que des recettes c'est-à-dire des temps
bibliques du couplet refrain telle idée
digne mais il n'y a pas de recette
chaque album que tu fais c'est un jeu
c'est jean claude lahr le cinéaste qui
disent à chaque film
c'est un prototype je sais pas chaque
album pour moi c'est un pas hormis au
top à l'image mais s'attend à fin mai
500 morceaux vite chose qu'ils voient
est ce que tu as des chansons que tu as
sorti dans les derniers albums que tu
traînes avec toi depuis des dizaines
d'années que tu avais laissé sur le côté
que tu avais dit accueille aujourd'hui
j'ai 3 milliards et toujours des
chansons que je laisse ce que je
hier en vieillissant mais j'en ai
beaucoup de chansons connues
c'est un avantage mais en vieillissement
en faisant des tournées de plus en plus
fous je laisse tomber 10 des pièces
connues mois fac et là j'en profite pour
tu vois ça je déplore jeu quand je lis
pas fait pendant mon dû peut-être une
dizaine d'années trois tournées
peut-être juste parce qu'elle est assez
c'est assez
ouais je sois jamais contre et petites
choses grand théâtre puis mon frère
maudit
c'était vraiment bon mais il ya pas de
projeter de la chance en plus on en
donne plus de monde en ville c'est en
plus en hauteur on était là en pensant
mais on est tous là à ce spectacle au
pis je me rappelle c'est qu'elle
tournait c'était palombes à gratter
j'ai pas fait ça donc je profite de ce
type là non plus c'est même ma
belle-mère a passé le même commentaire
que j'ai fais toi mais laquelle
ah ouais ouais dicamba je ne sais pas
bien c'est ça si la scène parce
scheppler on m'avait parlé de l'autre la
main belge ça c'est vous autres mais il
y en a d'autres qui kasaï à jouer telle
taille ajouté oui
accueilli à des sacrifices c'est faux
que ces 500 tonnes qui aujourd hui
plutôt qui l'inquiète est-ce que le live
demande beaucoup en ce moment non c'est
assez curieux parce que avant la
pandémie après pas l'hommage avait
décidé de prendre une pause de deux live
parce que c'est très c'est très exigeant
très intéressant aussi mais je me disant
je reçois faire une en tournée je
pourrais vous parler des désavantages de
la tournée mais il ya des avantages dans
tout et ce qui est ce que j'aime des
dernières tournées c'est que je l'aï
fait avec ma blonde donc sharon une
contrée mais c'est toute la tente
tu arrives dans une ville vers midi
attendre santé qui fait son check tatin
d'aller super super michaud pauvre le
schuss que je n'aurais je ne peux pas il
est aux belles heures tatatata que les
boys et reviennent l'instruction et le
tas temps de faire le show donc il ya
beaucoup d'attentes puis-je me je me
suis lassé de de ce ca a pris le dessus
ça a pris deux le dessus 2 sur le
plaisir de
de faire la tournée a aussi toute la
gestion du personnel je vous dis tout la
gestion du personnel partiront dizaines
de personnes toujours est ensemble puis
bon un des problèmes notre logis de
l'eau qui pourra pas venir les tice fait
remplacer et donc ce qui fait que ce
dont je m'ennuie le plus c'est ce que je
suis pro loin que ce sera le seul truc
que je serai en premier quand je
reviendrai c'est de partir en solo parce
qu'un seul où c'était autre chose ce qui
n'était que le sommet nucléaire a juste
peut-être non moins des fois
l'éclairagiste puis le docteur de avec
les instruments de musique t34 il ya
quelque chose de très très qui
s'apparente aussi aux chansonniers des
années 40 le taux de cette date est
quand même assez différente c'est moi
mon père il parle toujours de la tournée
rêver mieux comme étant un des
spectacles les plus plus magnifique rôle
de sa vie tu sais de quoi qui
s'apparente quasiment au spectacle de
pink floyd et verbier effet tout le we
puisse allah peut-être extrêmement
différent comme expérience de tourner
une tournée en solo puis en tournée
montée comme seul oui tout à fait
mais rêver mieux rêver mieux j'étais
serein j'étais sur un nuage vraiment
impôts pour deux raisons le substance
mais j'étais vraiment sur un nuage
c'est un vrai groupe l'album est sorti
comme quatre ou cinq cent quatre
semaines après les attentats du 11
septembre
donc il y avait une espèce de sexe comme
suit sa rentrée dans à ça fait du bien
c'est un album très empathique aussi
porté sur l'autre gt gt gt gt
complètement heureux de faire ce don qui
c'était c'est vrai que c'est un choix
exigeant à faire on avait beaucoup de
plaisir à le faire
quand tu es tellement qu'après la après
cette tournée lot de rêver mieux je suis
embarqué sur la tour la tournée de
l'échec du matériel et j'avais fait fi
d'une remarque de potes qui m'avait dit
ce que les titres négatifs souvent sa
sainte luce sur ton expérience de taille
du trouble non ça c'est pas le départ à
partir de la première entrevue que j'ai
fait avec l'échec du matériel où j'étais
ni plus ni moins en train de présenter
mon travail et du matériel donc acheter
le cd dans un monde commercial nous
tenons plus fallait que j'arrive en
échec
venez venez acheter ventilé acheté mon
échec non mais c'est pas complètement
sommet il y avait un peu de tout et donc
qui a je me suis dit qu'il y avait un
journaliste de radio canada qui m'avait
fait une entrevue de matin c'est pas un
peu contradictoire
oui merci du mieux penser c'est vrai que
la tournée a été complètement difficile
d'un point de vue avec les musiciens
avec tous tout a été dit si jusqu'au
jusqu'au dernier spectacle ou un
musicien qui menaçait de se présenter à
des menaces et chats ça m'a complètement
épuisé vraiment vraiment épuisé et je me
suis dit ah ça c'est terminé ça va être
mon titre d'album le plus négatif que
j'aurais eu de belles vite
jean remarquer justement que
tu attends j'ai pu beaucoup des
tendances album lost une période que
l'échec matériel merci beaucoup
une femme dans les dernières tournées se
mettre en pause je suis bon je faisais
juste à la manière de se projeter non
pas le crémant mois chip parce qu on
sait de quoi on va tout faire la manière
- un signe un départ je faisais celle-là
je pensais tout parce que c'est une
partie négative c'est noir c'est moi je
serais volontiers l'album tout seul un
âge où je le ferai tlf représente reid
avait fait avec son album birds in juste
l'album j'aime bien ce concept qui pas
c'est curieux ça échappe à la nostalgie
c'est juste fait l'album tout le monde
est content il n'y a pas de nostalgie
stuf l album c'est comme des
retrouvailles que l'album je suis très
très vivant comme expérience aux jeunes
prennent mais tu vois j'ai pas chanter
non plus de chansons de chic de belgique
non absolument j'en ai toujours aimé le
jeu je lis pas je n'ai pas fait mais moi
ça va être
je me garde du stock pour pour l'avenir
aussi parce que c'est ce que je fasse
chic de ville jean phase iv à la manière
que je suis mon prochain album
moi je les intègre beaucoup non dans le
projet que je présente fait que ce qui
me permettait de faire comme le ton je
me souviens dans la tournée rêver mieux
je faisais sortez moi de moi beaucoup à
la manière de ouais quand je peux
trouver une façon de la faire une
chanson de la réanimer
à mon goût mais je le fais avec l'échec
du matériel tête dans prochaine tournée
il y aura plus de
cela dit je fais encore de la tournée je
dis que je sais plus je prends une pause
mais il y en a encore pour un peu forcé
en ce moment c'est gênant dire que la
pandémie tombe bien pour voir comment
comment tu utilises ton temps pendant la
pandémie
tu disais je pense à tout le monde en
parle que tu passe énormément de temps
en studio
ben oui mais moins confiné
de toute façon j'ai ma nature je vois
tous les jour vaquaient pas des mieux
pour gérer vos studios et pains chauds
comme d'habitude eu la seule comme jeudi
la seule différence c'est ma vie sociale
en dehors de ce je prenais mon café
avant pendant la pandémie c'était firme
effectué les panneaux par action qu'à
faire mais je me faisais un café au
studio de table est incorrect fois que
j'ai travaillé sur par exemple sur
tabling je travaille sur mon prochain
album de chansons je travaillais sur la
musique de film le prochain film de luc
picard série limitée afin que je
trouvais là dessus donc j'ai pas manqué
de pas manquer du tout de travail et
comme c'était prévu que j'allais pas est
en tournée cette année riche montant
était voué à la composent non mais c'est
quoi le coup le processus de mam en
béton qui est écrit une chanson ce
moment que jusqu'au moment qui se
termine est est ce que j'imagine que le
temps qui passe et seule la manie des
gens qui viennent j'ai tous sur le belge
fait de plus en plus tout ce que je
voyais justement ce autre chose ligne
vous je voyais que tu joues la grande
majorité de l'instrument oui oui oui
avant je faisais pas ça j'avais joué
mais je n'avais pas la confiance de le
faire je le fais il a fait je peux pas
faire comme sur palau mais les trois
chansons je pense est un vrai batteur
qui est venu et jeff le mieux qu'ils
jouaient de la bei
mais pour le reste quand je peux le
faire je le fais et quand je peux le
faire je le fais si ça reste vivant
quand je le fais ça reste pose des fois
ci comme meetic quand tu fais tout pour
ça ça semble elle insiste le mal le plus
preuve qu'elle la musique peut se
rapprocher mais c'est tout le monde
cauchon pour faire la métaphore la plus
difficile
il ya quelqu'un qui ya eu ces américains
qui me souviens plus du nom de suite là
il fait tout sur son album à qui comment
si julie joue la 'base sa guitare il est
possible de la baisse pas pressé mais
nous sommes là pressé il recommence la
baisse puis peut-être qu'ils
recommencent les médias commencent donc
tout seul ça finit par avoir une espèce
de cohésion et mais moi j'ai pas la
patience
puis j'ai pas de batterie ce le seul
instrument que je suis pas là de 32 à
moins d'une petit job de batterie un
spectacle ce qui différencie le plus d
autres aussi le haut niveau au niveau du
fait que c'est pas des billets pas
d'accord avec ta batterie
peut-être que c'est son job de bataille
je cherchais musiciens un batteur n'ont
émis si les baisses des taux de change a
pesé même coup ses wagons
elijah wood accord de nice sur tout
exact est-ce que
est-ce que tu écoute beaucoup de musique
dans son processus de composition
non c'est le moment où je n'écoute les
mal logés par de la musique des autres
caisses environnement super tu
connaissais tu composes aussi que moi ta
part que juste entendu une bonne toune
la veille puis le lendemain de son bond
est aujourd'hui sa lutte pas fini ta
journée tombe les radios puis tentant sa
chance au brésil parce que c'est
exactement temps du fait que j'ai un peu
peur de ce que j'en écoute mais papa pas
autant que quand je suis un peu fouillis
faut dire aussi que c'est pas la musique
qui m'inspire la musique qui sait pas
c'est souvent la production de la
musique qui qui vomit inspirer parce que
je trouve qu'on est plus dans un monde
de production de chansons que de
composition vraiment donc c'est là c'est
la production c'est le son final qui
fait que
qui fait la chanson je trouve ça prend
une bonne chanson la production finale
c'est là que se trouve seul le plus
d'innovations pixels
je trouve la production ou c est
vraiment les outils de la production de
toutes les nouveautés les gadgets
nouveau nul et alors ce qui m'inspire le
plus plu des arts visuels particules
parce que de 1,6 silencieux je regarde
un de toi tu peux pas la copie en
musique ne pige pas la copie que jusqu à
transposer c'est très bien donc
l'énergie de l'art visuel ça j'aime
beaucoup ça sérieux progrès parce que
c'est cela suppose mais je peux t on
passe des buteurs des 10 en 8 es
remettons par jour avec des écouteurs ce
que je vous disais que je suis mais
modeste comme une coiffeuse qui masquait
j'en ai longuement limite masquer mon
jeu c'est mon petit facteur aussi qui te
demande pas un facteur d'aller prendre
une marche près tous les prêts sont la
production justement cette recherche
sonore c'est un peu le mal aimé d'une
chanson dans ce sens que c'est tellement
ces préjugés non mais aussi c'est
tellement de travail peu d'attention aux
détails puis de recherche pour arriver à
chanter sur un album we mérité que tu
veux pitt et on l'entend dans tes albums
c'est cette recherche le tir et chaque
album une signature sonore vient de
recherche aux normes c'est vraiment et
layton di meco moins sont recherchées
son travail est petit ou passent
énormément de temps à essayer de
découvrir ce petit et pis mais ton par
rapport aux textes qui tout aussi
important mais en entrevue choc on parle
tout le temps des textes plus jamais de
la production tombe est une chanson
c'est vraiment comme
t comme le berger de 150 moutons faut
que les moutons ait eu les moutons c'est
les espaces et la production
donc il ya toujours une tombe pas le
faut que tu la ramènes il faut que tout
athlète a été ton tout poules moutons il
exact jusque dans l'arc look et essaye
de garder que tout le ton de moutons que
sky est un loup cela sarramon ac c'est
un peu comme ça puis tout est pas
intellectualiser comme ça pour moi c'est
très intuitif
j'arrive pas toujours exprimé à
quelqu'un ou à personne qui voit qu'ils
vont mixé par exemple ce que je veux
vraiment chez du pièce par pièce
ils vont me faire un mixte renonce au
futur c'est comme ça mais j'arrive pas
il donna une direction très très très
clairs au mix de toute façon aussi comme
j'ai un studio
la production a défini chaque jour puis
finalement gars qui voit mme x et y voit
ça va commencer a semblé devoir compris
vous rien enlever à celui qui est mixé
air de glace comme par exemple c'est
sensiblement le même mix que moi mais
juste plus autoritaire juste plus
solides moi mais il ya déjà là la photo
du mx1 jusqu'au errante et lier les
rapports de volume ni rapport de sens
pas mal tout le
cela dit je suis pas un mixeur c'est
pour rien s'est réuni pour enlever aux
milles ça parce que le mr ont toutes
sortes de de sa tribu ni clous et c'est
très technique puis
si créatif et technique à la fois sauf
que oui tout ça arrive avec et tonton
refuzniks justement ton idée après celui
vos justes grande si justement comme
c'était un peu plus clair un petit peu
plus cohérent mais formative dans le bon
sens moi je suis en dessous il voit
juste à aider ce que tous les faits
soient favorisés donc c'est ce que
claude champagne fait avec heures de
glace faut qu'il faut quand même que ça
qui a une certaine connexion une
certaine compréhension entre l'artiste
pile producteurs et oui et non c'est à
dire que j'ai déjà envoyé un mixeur avec
panneaux menget envoyé des mix à los
angele 1,1 go qui mixe kita qui a
travaillé le jeu le nombre n'ont pu me
revient peau mais les filles il fait du
heavy métal puis le gaucher autographes
ian avec qui je travaillais en temps de
renvoyer sur ce monsieur lopez qui
travaillent le sans gêne dans son studio
à lille on devrait envoyer ça pour voir
ce que ça et donc toutes mes chansons et
à 0 tel est notre mix connu petit tout
est flat et je n'ai pas envoyé de refus
on l'aurait fait ce que tu es avec
certes courageux ben c'est c'est pas
tellement du courage comme comme mai
tous les voir quelqu'un qui me connaît
pas sur un mix donc pas grandi avec ce
week-end c'est jim corcoran que vous
connaissez le jour j ai quitté jamie
bertrand pelé il fait des albums fait
trois quatre albums de un jour il
travaillait dans studio pilotes essayent
d'aller ailleurs que en dj mais bertrand
ou du jean et un musicien qui lui
collent à chaque fois qu'il voulait
quelque chose qui demandait quelque
chose le musicien joue m et puis ça
finit toujours me dire ouais c'est pas
ça fait pas c'est pas jim barker et
l'oeil 606 ben non ça est un jour qui
était d'en importer de l'aca quand il
rencontre car marche qui réalisateur qui
habite à langil
puis il se lie d'amitié des toilettes à
cela valide la place où les grands de ce
prix sera encore oui je sois tu vois
même pas regardé pouvoir faire comme
cela personne existait fait secteur où
vous allez parler vous n'avez pas le
choix
donc il est imité en achever la défaire
ses chansons et là il était le cheval
pour jim mais je pense qu'ils aient
symantec
ils vont le faire on va éviter le oui et
et donc la bonne demande et tout ce
qu'ils voulaient où on multiplie me suis
jamais fait passer trouvé qu'une liberté
d'accès un peu sa hausse et envoyer les
mixes ailleurs il mixe peau comme il
avec la précède pas la chanson c'est la
chanson pas plus à ce qu'il était
vraiment c'était sympathique fait plus
que sympathique me plaît le t-rex chaque
fois pourquoi j'ai pu j'ai pris un
complément puis je me sentais que
quelque chose de surréaliste de se faire
dire par quelqu'un d'autre ça ça fait
pas toi tu sais tu y ait eu quelque
chose comme ça c'est pas toi oui c'est
ça doit te [ __ ] mais non le c'est pas
toi
oui c'était quand même mieux pour moi
c'était moi je peux sentir de jim walton
j'ai fait cet exercice là d'envoyer une
prod que j'ai fait à los angeles
ça a été une catastrophe catastrophe
très bon chemin qu'on en parle
la bombe était moins fait ça a été
vraiment différent l'expérience a été
assez écolo jean son travail normalement
bezzate de l'eau sage oui puis qui j'ai
l'impression que lui ça a été oh le
petit contrôle du québec
johnson avait près midi pile allons
vivre c'est rare qu'ils sont comme ça j
en profite pour prendre un break de ce
qu'ils font il ya 30 ans parce que ça
hypothèque du mois c'est sûr dit je te
voyais ça a pris beaucoup de banques une
fois il pas menotté comme elle le ca
fait comme trop version je t'envoie
n'était pas cité de nom comme ça c'est
comme ces petites encaisse mal dire que
je tripote et tout n'est pas
extraordinaire l'extérieur du québec tu
sais ces informateurs situé vote il va
pour du changement pour trouver mieux
tu peux trouver s'est mieux passé chargé
mais c'est pas parce que ses supérieurs
je pense pas que c'est juste va faire un
tour de charme une honte aux tats-unis
une sorte de yei testant un monde par sa
tante de roulis ce tout autre l'otan ça
m'est arrivé une fois par j'ai envoyé
deux ou trois chansons je pense de nous
pour la fin mastery à new york puis
chief software is jeter vraiment c'est à
quoi donc c'était pas du mans peut-être
pas nous mais peut-être finalement lui
il comprenait que ce n'était pas notre
que ça marche se fait finalement in the
du véloce prochaine prochain projet mené
les je vous le fais sur le beau nom
ouais mais c'est seb et moi la leçon que
doit tirer de ça c'est aussi fatwa
confiance et dans le fond c'est oui oui
c'est pas on pense toujours que les
autres on aurait meilleures boutiques et
jeta mal élite quand même oui c'est
juste j'ai des regrets des banques n'est
pas bon existe des chefs en cuisine qui
met trop de sel est le sens j'ai lu les
grands chefs
avec une carrière aussi longue que la
tienne qui continue encore maintenant tu
as vu quand même le paysage musical
changer quels sont les changements que
remarquée qui était le plus flagrant
c'est dans la façon évidemment que les
gens consomment la musique personnes qui
achètent des cd de copie diffusée
matériel la façon que la musique qui
produit la façon que par exemple les
lily ça c'est la pause pipi pour ceux
qui se présentent aux lettres des
[ __ ] allez voir sur youtube
c'est très visuel ne tentez pas cela la
maison certains jeunes habana le domaine
musical et graphique pour moi c'est le
trafic vraiment beaucoup de monde
vraiment beaucoup de monde mais je m'en
plains pas car dès qu'il trouve sa
touche je voyais des vieilles croûtes
dans mon temps un peu moins de monde la
meilleure plus facile pour les élus
après soeur tu avais d'autres qui qui
qui stores gueuler pour y arriver
mais en ce moment fait aussi il y avait
sept services et avantages aussi d'être
backé par un les bosses de dire que
c'est comme une librairie c'est que
souvent dans cette librairie les autres
sont très sens politique du moins c'est
ça donc des signatures fait que c'est
leur entrée dans ce milieu-là quant aux
besoins nomades store oui mais excuse
moi juste pour
j'ai oublié mon démon fait donc plus de
musique de chambre classique mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres produits auto produit
et ça a donné ça a donné des grandes
choses comme la petite dernière british
temps et comme j'ai aucun nom a été
littéralement dans sa chasse libye c'est
la plus grande superstar en ce moment
incroyable crédibilité de 12,2 d'auteurs
compositeurs aussi c'est pas mettre tout
le reste ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
pollution il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
trafic
puis il a la crainte aussi c'est que
souvent c'est un architecte qui m'avait
dit c'est toujours les gens poche qui
tue les genres dans man architecture
déjà et donc ça ça se vérifie un peu
c'est un peu ce que c'est ma seule
crainte c'est que que tu ailles kata et
des poches qui saturent mais qui décide
que ses poches c'est paulo mais moins
que lyon 12 émules des boulangers qui
font des versions proche de 20 points
qui quand la manière 2 août à des
producteurs le rôle du méchant produits
la voilà qui veulent avoir du mal à
personne je serai donc
eux c'est ça il ya des producteurs qui
veulent profiter d'un courant puis le
gard environ 4 dans le même genre je
sais pas du tout si vrai que ça mais
c'est juste ça se peut que tendre plus
de chansons paraît en ce moment que yo
longtemps il faut que tu fasses vos tu
travailles fort pour garder la patience
d'écouter tout le monde puis de dire ça
ça me touche tu ça mais ça c'est le pour
moi ça la grosse différence
mais en même temps ce n'est spes de
démocratisation de la musique bien sûr
mais avec les défauts que ça avec
quelques défauts sans le côté sombre de
temps il ya une espèce de da proches se
mettant avec les patrons préfèrent
appeler musique sa télé les musiques
sont souvent triés par mme houde était
pareil parra ou pas utilisés pour
s'entraîner musique pour 6 a fait que
jacques - l'album les gens écoutaient
aux jeux jeux films musique piano d'où
ce soit plus mais fut le likoud droite
s'est peu importe ils sont fans de genre
jusque fin mai je pense que tout le
monde de son art son artiste préféré
quand même eu un meilleur saut aussi
puis on est aussi un peu dans une
culture de l'espèce de retour de deux 45
tours cédé 1,62 et coûté 260 doute
acheté pas un album et je pense acheter
un 45 tours
d'acheter des cartes et des tablettes
deux tours donc en ce moment je trouve
que c'est un peu ce que je te de feeling
là puis aussi une indifférence à cause
de la saturation la musique est vraiment
beaucoup par tous les joueurs c'est vrai
que les gens jamais autant écouter la
musique on est on n'écoutait pas la
musique dans rue le bon moi j'ai connu
le l'arrivée du duo walkman titre
ordinaire met donc en 75 c'est écouter
la musique chez vous dans ta chambre
dans total ont acheté moins de témoins
n'étaient pas abonnée au grec sait plus
ces curieuses comme plus facile et plus
d'ici là maintenant de trouver
je connais mon ski va durer peut-être
des plus plus c'est difficile plus pris
un effort aller chercher la musique
assise sur le récit le sprint et un
buffet à volonté de deux plus que toutes
les musiques du monde à n'importe quel
instant c'est quand de valeo magasin et
acheter ton ton vinyle revenir à maison
tu installes écouter écouter la pochette
s'il tournait fracture à l'épaule je
viens de passer à péta tous à la même
heure avant d'être abonné acheter des
albums je les écoutais peau j'écoute une
tournée dans la joie l'écouté plus tard
finalement j'ai pas comment c'est un
homme c'était face à qui il y aussi la
tâche at il dit
mais on dirait que c'est comme c'est
très facile puis moi on dirait que j'ai
dans la façon que j'ai que la musique
maintenant jusqu'en j'étais en train de
faire des activités connexes est
vraiment alors que j'écoute de la
musique est mon activité sur écoute et
que je m'arrête pour écouter ce que sa
compagne se joint sa accompagne tout le
temps quelque chose on se souvient
toujours secondaire dans ce que j'étais
en train de faire
puis je me rappelle pas moi je te un
amateur de parole
si c'est vraiment ce qui vient me
chercher en premier mais c'est ce que je
retiens le plus mais je me rappelle même
poids dans les dernières années avoir eu
des paroles avoir un coup de coeur pour
un texte c puis je suis persuadé que
c'est pas parce que plus de bons textes
qui se fait loin de là mais ça me
rappelle le temps justement
moi j'ai tripé énormément sur tes textes
puis je me rappelle précisément de
d'avoir écouté les albums au complet
puis d'avoir juste me concentrer de
mettre juste concentré sur les textes
ouais mais là je le fais plus ouais on
dirait que la dernière fois mettant le
dernier souvenir que j'ai c'est les
grandes artères de louge encore mis le
dernier album que j'ai vraiment je pense
a fait sien je me suis vraiment
concentré sur les courts depuis sur les
textes
ok c'est malheureux parce que je sais
que plein d'artistes en ce moment qui
font d excellent texte est prêt mais
c'est une saturation - mais des fois il
ya les changements ça change il ya des
changements qui arrive poussée des
mouvements
c'est comme s'il fait pu arrêter ce
mouvement le au pire quand les artistes
en ce moment et c'est pas le sait pas on
n'est pas dans le cinq ans oui on le
fait le plus d'argent
les honoraires compris cela donc c'est
pilic producteurs et encore moins mais
l'auteur compositeur lui dans son
histoire depuis le début des temps le
ils étaient dans la rue chantonnant vu
kim en est long il vient de pagnes 1 125
ans à peu près 2
phonographie peut en tirer des hypers
gagner sa vie pour vrai et le et le ca
marche plus et là c'est parce qu'il a de
l'argent c'est juste le 1 % au qui en
fait puisqu'il doit littéralement de
l'argent mais légalement parce qu'il
n'ya pas spotify puis à paimpol qui
respectent pas la loi canadienne
ils s'en remettent à la loi lors les
autistes bennoo l'on respecte la loi et
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya peut-être 4
5 1 me dire comment la crise du disque
est plus qu est ce que tu en penses bien
je dis oui c'est la crise du disque mais
c'est pas la crise de de l'auteur
compositeur il ya toujours existé il va
malheureusement peut-être juste s'en
retourner dans rue hamra médecin quand
il valait mieux une épisode que du riz
cependant vous pouvez gagner leur vie
avec ce club et il s'en retourne dans la
rue c'est pas que je suis pour mais
avant qu'on tue les auteurs compositeurs
parce que c'est une pulsion que lui en
fait il y en fait un mode de vie il en
fait pas une business alors que c'est
vraiment un problème c'est une crise du
disque no 10 qui est en crise et la
baisse leur faudrait que invitiez un
producteur pour vous en parler parce que
moi ces pauses pour mon rayon malgré que
j'ai de l'empathie et puis il est mon
frère est pas du tout âge puisque né
jésus
j'arrive dans le monde le producteur je
ne souhaite pas de crever mais ce
essayons évoquant les problèmes
c'est vers nous aussi dans notre
histoire de d'artistes ont beau jeu sur
ce tour nine parce que c'était dans la
bohème au ni ni
c'est tout c'est sûr que ça va compter
la chanson vous conseille d'exister les
artistes on continue de composer et
d'écrire des chansons c'est juste que
chose de triste a dit dans la société on
on considère poti ou que ça soit pas
qu'un primitif damas a plus ou moins
atroces qui capote et avec les artistes
c'est qu'on passe notre vous allez voir
un spectacle
puis tu regardes je suis pour tout
nouveau tout beau doublé et j'habite ce
travail devait tout d'abord dans le lot
naturel ils font le show le show
business depuis le début des temps fait
tout pour avoir la mode sur l on voit là
de travailler pendant qu'ils font parce
qu'ils veulent c'est pas leur mandat ils
veulent pas qu'être centre le fardeau du
travail tu veux pas qu'il cite si tu
veux pas que tu profites tu veux pas
voir quelqu'un qui travaille mais oui 80
chaudes se voit quelqu'un qui s'ils
n'ont pas rajouté naturel d'étude et
boucle le travail ne paraît pas et plus
le show est bon plus à leurs faciles
plus simples et moins le plus
travaillent fort que ça passera par là
dessus est donc c'est capoté en ce
moment parce qu'ils foutent l'ofs ça
fait très longtemps quel show business
pas convaincu tout le monde que cadet
faut pas que montrer qu'on travaille et
leurs vassaux convaincre les gens du
contraire on travaille
il faut gagner ma vie c'est vrai je suis
le début du piratage est peut-être une
dizaine d'années je sortais au
gouvernement il y en avait qui piquent
copier de la musique sur son cv quoi
c'est de la m
c'est à moi le sait de l'air mais je
donc il ya une compréhension tout
commence à arriver le gouvernement puis
encore 0 lien qui qu il rien ne change
et une grosse business et beaucoup
d'argent mais l'espace laissé plateforme
le sait tellement pour le prix d'un
album taxés à tous les albigeois pop hip
moins cher pour moins cher qu'un album
et c'est tout le monde était payé ce que
ça ce que ça vaut aussi qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient avec le cd puis le libre c'est
l'artiste aime y était mieux rémunérés
t'apprêtes à bon c'est vrai problème
c'est dans ce sens que pour gagner notre
vie pour les lycées météo mais je
comprends complètement le consommateur
de crime
c'est légal pee wee pas seulement aux
consommateurs ce cadre à l'amusement on
est dans le divertissement picchu vrai
que que je réfléchisse ça comme une
business c'est chez ses principaux
chevaux consommateurs à réfléchir là
dessus ce sont je pense parce que tu ne
trouves pas l'accabler de salluit en
plus que pays en paix on voit pas le lac
arabe ligue 2 du grand malheur de c'est
vrai c'est en tant que tenant du titre
et chaque jour je m'élève puma au studio
6 ouais mais c'est quelque chose qui qui
qui qui peut qui peut dans la tête des
gens c'est pas sur la conception de
screens pour les options de l'artiste
pour bouffer romantique une personne
d'aller bélanger il doit prendre une
marche dans le bois qui composent
l'album one heart à fait présentable
une pièce mon pauvre on peut donc qui se
trouve être déductibles des besoins
pratiques et des chansons avec ton pied
sur toute la faune les biens sur le
contour mais j'ai fait poser contourne
marc mais ouais mon pied dessus un jour
je faisais le jade fr bientôt le
spectrum je pense que pour monter dans
le désordre
j'avais acheté 1 bat ring top ça vous
dit que toi produits non non c'était pas
battling top c'était la souris est un
jeu d 1,60 ce que le nb200 plus apte à
sauter bien plongeurs afin équipe
l'espèce de l'engrenage de patente sur
un ton juste ce site est donc jamais je
l'avais acheté pour mon travail je
voulant prendre l'exemple du mondistes
façonnant spectrum de faire des trucs
qui habitait le spectrum au complet
la porte expliqué c'est quoi
l'utilisation activité le train survenu
au pouf tout renato marché comme ça
l'idée non non mais on a fait autre
chose de complètement capoté le style et
le rideau s'ouvre au centre ok j'ai ton
petit mais très doux qui ouvrait donc et
ça comme une demi lune et le rideau à la
moitié y aurait d'autres motifs
sauf que au début car les pions l'avait
fait une grosse demi lune en avant on
avait rallongé le la scène du métropolis
du spectrum donc quand les gens
arrivaient ils voyaient tous les
instruments il veut y être mais là quand
l'ennemi a fermé le rideau se ferme et
éloquence house reste il y avait des
projections en arrière donc c'est vrai
ça faisait comme une espèce de gpo le
vaisseau spatial qui arrive est donc
faible
c'est la fois outil sur trois semaines
c'était une résidence j'espère qu'un
jour ça vaut la peine de le faire non
trois fois cinq jours de suite
ah ouais il savait tu étais pas où vous
habitez au succès supplémentaires
est ce que tu sens que c'est possible
encore aujourd'hui d'avoir pour mme et
ont essayé de prendre l'histoire que tu
viens de raconter d'une résidence de
quinze jours soldats avec ce combat là
rend ce que tu crois que c'est possible
maintenant d'avoir un engouement comme
ceux autour d'un autour d'un spectacle
autour d'une oeuvre artistique
c'est dans ce cas là c'était pour quatre
saisons et des autres partis si l'image
est plus un typiquement un phénomène
social au moment que ça a dû sortir et
moi c'était c'était quatre saisons dans
les ordres étaient très attendus petit
fils de 4 ans repose sur son album est
donc avait avant ming qui sort qui avait
comme si j'étais disques durs qu'ils
étaient 50 millions qu'avait cinquante
mille commandes d'un magazine ont été
scientifiquement même qui suit wifaq il
y avait juste juste cette anecdote là je
peux plus jamais c'est fini
lorsque la mesure de ces déterminer ça
va être la mesure des vues ou du même
coup à la cheville face à l'engouement
mettons gc ca je suis je ne sais pas je
sais pas qui je sais pas et c'est parce
que moi je me vois si je vois pas je
vais répondre année en fait trois fois
mais trop police puis la troisième
soirée
ça a pris du temps avant que je pense
pas qu'ils pourraient rester trois
semaines au météo dans une grosse salle
sold out c'est que beaucoup d'offres en
ce moment' rodophe puisque tu peux pas
de pays le cinquième choix tu aller
boire je sais pas mais je sais pas il
semble que oui je pense marie mai la
fête vers pas longtemps j'en ai trois
semaines où wim tellier non mal est fait
beaucoup de soirées où on sent derrière
mais toutes ces personnes au centre bell
jusqu'aux u13 c est ce que dans ces
années là
est ce que tu as vécu ton rock ici oui
en images parce que l'image que j'ai de
daniel bélanger c'est quelqu'un est
quand même introverti que le jeter du
sud devant toi corrigez moi si je me
trompe mais ce qui est quand même être
ouverte si qui rentre à l'hôtel après
son spectacle pour pour se coucher pipi
se lever le lendemain puis recommencez
de façon assez méthodique
oui oui c'est un peu cependant sur mes
mots ce que j'aime vivre mon rock mais
monsieur j'aime les ventes est mort
quand j'ai fait la résidence au spectrum
pendant trois semaines après qu'elle lui
ait des fois mais ton qui ne fait pas
les uns ou un soir par semaine ne pourra
pas dire de bêtises je partais de
spectrum et puis je m'en allant charmant
j'ai bon dur c'est dur de une patate
c'est 800 jax de l'échangeur turcot
chila fla ouais ouais je les collais
agence à côté le team entier de
connaître un triomphe finalement eu
triompher la peau des bouteilles de
champagne
olam est bon de olaf la période sans
problème sans vraiment
1 au top pour moi je restais ce que j'ai
été avec les rêves que j'avais pu je
revenais me your dog et
c'était très spécial pour moi c'est par
que je fais sans me tromper
un bon gros show ou intéligent pas très
apportée voire la meilleure bouteille
devant aller manger ça peut arriver mais
je suis plutôt j'aime j'aime le
contraste ça fait d'aller à les terminer
saut avec quelque chose pour moi de très
rock là dedans et instamment mesure sam
si c'est à moi ça me fait triper très
très fort d'abord les deux d'avoir un
gros succès après soeur revenir ce que
j'aime le plus de ce que je fais cette
truite un peu kate et non rue peel
manger moins dalpé je suis fière
ça me fait peur face andrietti si mes
shows les plus précaires
c'est le propos était contre x et ultra
je pose une limite et la dalle on dirait
deux comme redevenir à revenait à
quelque chose de super je trouve ça
tellement aimé dans le centre c'est très
puissant pour moi ça cherche quelque
chose de puissant donc en a qui
cherchent un fixe moi mon fixe y ait la
main donc comme ou revenir un vélo après
un gros succès ou une telle issue me
promener dans la rue le soir ortoli une
heure du matin jean miché nous pour moi
c'est le très grand luxe pour moi de
pouvoir faire ça pis en plus au québec
on vous saute pas dessus le cas donc à
une d'environ me sourie t cesser ces
pratiques manquera devenir le lagon 17
ans vélo pitt juste de laffrey le
scénith wali s'est vraiment
c'est le sait bien plus tôt pour moi
d'être invité un cocktail et l'api de ça
m'amuse patins c'est pas aussi puissante
juste fan j'ai même ne sait pas aussi
puissant que je me retrouvais dans pi 2
de me retrouver avec les règles que
j'avais qui sont réalisées au taux est
ce qu'il ya un moment parce que il a
fallu qu'ils parlent se disent c'est
babu le succès maîtrise pas ce montant
atteint maintenant je suis normale et
non j'étais j'ai toujours peur de ce que
parce que il ya eu des précédents mais
toujours par te dit contemporain aussi
qu'ils sont orient le panneau la vue des
gens autour de moi qui mets c'était pas
moi même c'était il y en a qui qui qui
voulait faire ça pour le pour le mode de
vie rock qui naît avec
mais je touche carré quand je suis
malgré tout les projets sont acceptables
savoir je souffre de la musique qu'il
sait pas s'ils purent que ceux-là mais
je voulais faire de la musique puis
après ça on devient une vedette
on va prendre certains bugs qui studio
c'est possible que ça danse ancienne
partie des gonades dame devait sûrement
sûrement pourquoi vouloir faire pourquoi
enfin que je valais sur une scène pablo
des synthés il doit voir elle m'est
témoin je viens aussi d'un milieu plutôt
modeste medal classe puis mon père c'est
celui qui jouait de la guitare dans les
parties fin que finalement la fin de la
fin de partie enfin le toujours que
rogers centre ha puis ça lui donnait
beaucoup le trac parce que ma mère cette
grosse famille
trop de familles et de la dernière d'une
très très enfantin et là où mon père est
un peu
celui qui chantait des limes des trucs
avec tout le monde aux sangles autres
sites étaient que mon retour way he said
onefs vraiment beaucoup de trac toute la
soirée arte de faire avec
ils sont six frères et soeurs et si
c'est un peu comme si avant une mini
foule d'idées ça sent pas bon pour le
corps t'as pas avantagés que le
treizième de ne pas se retrouver dans
des parts avec ketchup à 110 personnes
l'épilogué y chanter moi je le voyais je
voyais le plaisir que les gens va
l'entourent d'écouter mon peuple et 10e
trous des chansons invraisemblable je
voyais plaisir que ça faisait aussi puis
je voyais que c'était je voyais que ça
avait là le fond de sa ferme on perd un
peu le trac avant de le faire il faisait
presque fait que c'est sûr qu' il faut
une mine par dégoût mais j'essaye
d'avoir les goûts d'abord parce que ce
que je voulais dire aussi c'est que dans
ces parties là il y avait vraiment du
fight ça il y avait une cohésion une
union pilar tout le monde était à soyaux
dans la même classe puisse à ce procès
là et ça j'ai toujours aimé ça quand je
fais un show que tout le monde ait
l'appui que puis c'est l'endroit où je
suis très à l'aise sur une scène je suis
plus à l'aise car tv ou entrer dans un
restaurant ou deux sur scène c'est comme
j'aime ça j'aime les coulisses j'aime et
je me lâche un monde que j'aime pas
quand ça se passe un soir puis que tout
le monde du vin dit fan depuis que
surtout pas lui au mans sa première fois
je vivais ça les délits fille sur les
épaules de leurs jobs pique et pourtant
c'est pas le plus rock le
ah oui pas que ça est-ce que et pourtant
et comme j'ai fait beaucoup de scène je
push je m'en passerai jamais mais je
pourrais m'en passer ça ne fait que je
pense que je pouvais s'il m'arrive une
merde perdre la voir perdre je peux quoi
cash de tout je dois je pense que
sagement aux quelque chose qui rongerait
à l'intérieur et man turbo métier j'ai
jamais arrêté 50 faire 10 pour mon
intention là mais peut-être que pokémon
jeu mais j'ai mon rythme et ressent
lorsque je fais un album aux deux trois
heures pendant tournée factice des
tournées aux 3 1 est-ce que c'est quoi
la dans le fond là la phase des
créations permettons de l'enregistrement
des conditions d'enregistrement à la
tournée ce laquelle le laptop pour toile
ce que c'est d'aller livrer sans chose
que c'est la création studio ce que
c'est je pense la création en studio
c'est vraiment le fun c'est une pâte
stress juste disponible
tout est possible c'est vraiment pour
moi beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir l'autre
plaisir après c'est au bout de au bout
d'une vingtaine de chevaux de la cantine
faire le choc que tu sais que tu tues
depuis qu'un stress le petit stress
juste maîtrise mettons tout je regarde
presque plus pc lors de tes chansons tu
connais tout est naturel 3,4 pour fou
assassin chorégraphique est vraiment est
très chouette ça me dérange pas de
refaire quelque chose qui a marché
cette au long du show tu peux tu te
montre aussi ce que tu dis entre les
chansons donc faire la même chose
ben oui puis moi je vous vois pas de je
vois pas de trop avec ça j'ai pas jeudi
j'ai pas un problème de répétition sur
ces l'api les chansons que j'ai décidé
de faire content dé faire je voulais
faire cinquante fois sérieux ça me
dérange pas sa culotte quand le show est
bien rodée puisque ça tout est naturel
que l'autre pu regarder multiple trouvé
que ce qui vient de faire c'est vraiment
faire une dame puis trouvé formidable
qu'elle fit encore la pause formidable
que fait la veille puis accepte l'enfant
moi c'est pas pour moi c'est point ça je
ne sais pas un déficit de créativité
unique de recommencer ce que te fait
hier d'extraordinaire de trouver de quoi
on reproduit villette et ça marche
perfectionnez quelque chose s'est creusé
à chaque fois philippe pouillé team est
en jeu donc je vais et une anecdote
c'est personnel n'était pas si j'étais
guitariste dans mamma mia
louise can put et on a fait le show une
quarantaine de fois même plus qu' il n'y
a pas une fois où est ce que le monde
est venu punch et le piégeage et qui ont
fait le show pied et à chaque fois
c'était il ya onze ans le rendu comme se
plaît à tout le monde voulait beaucoup
d'implication du monde voulait le
perfectionner encore à chaque fois à
l'eau niveau de ces pillages et je te
crois aux victimes
on se fait prendre dans ce jeu look et
le moment où est ce que je te demande tu
lui laisses faire ce type hui que tu
veux le pot cette quête loi cette
recherche mais aussi et c'est là que je
pense ça devient plate en fait parce que
les yeux c'est là que
c'est là que tu joues pour toi tout seul
peut-être temps qui est temps que thor
en tête celui qui vote entendre tant que
tu va vouloir faire plaisir que tu vas y
tire quand tu dis le peaufiner pour fini
pour finir c'est vraiment encore pour
revenir comme temps tout c'est pour que
ça ait l'air encore moins du travail oit
silhouette que ça roule piquet s'était
professionnels
ça fait rêver aussi de pouvoir des
forces au sol
c'est pas négligeable que c'était pour
me faire un p'tit un petit retour sur
toi il y avait eu la vie il y avait une
bonne affaire quand même ouais je ne me
souviens pas exactement
tu es je me suis mis son nom le thé ton
passionné ce qu'il joue aussi avec la
ville
oui il y avait accroché son club dans le
milieu de la torre au début de la table
c'était merveilleux
philip roth au micro excusez pas voulu
daniel parle était magnifique s'excuser
black avait pas de l'eau des genoux des
fois des erreurs comme ce fut aussi un
moment unique
il faut dire aussi que moi j'ai jamais
de problème à me tromper a recommencé à
ce qui arrive quelque chose parce que
vous en souvenez mais ça sera la fin les
choses je leur ferai pour le lendemain
alain tu peux le faire une fois mais pas
deux jérémy alain quirion
c'est vraiment c'était avant de rentrer
sur scène à peu près tout le temps
bolognais ont été jetés par quatre ou
cinq
le batave qu'il vient faire et à chaque
fois il faisait une imitation de céder
comme il était dans un béton dans un
quatuor classique puis il faisait il
faisait semblant tenir son violoncelle
puis sont archi puis mais il y avait une
attitude de rock et donc à chaque soir
il y avait des personnages comme ça et
aussi il y avait des relâchements
intestinaux avant de rentrer fax qui
fait que ça fait rire tout le temps est
arrivé vraiment excité sur scène et on
le garde
mais bon chapeau chapeau bas n'en
d'ailleurs de se tourner l'os
oui c'était beau jean françois lemieux à
la basse puis elle explique marne qui
quittent que j'ai appris deux journées
le touriste drôme parce que quand est
venu le temps de monter le
le chaud par moments je les appelais
j'avais déjà fait une tournée avec lui
oui je vois deux rames ouais ça c'est le
genre d'appel qui foire seront reçus non
non je m'écoute un peu qu'on fait des
prochains mois combien d'heures mais ça
arrive donc j'appelle alex jardin oui ça
me tente autant de matches bobet c'est
super qu'ils aillent est géré par
tourner au drame
les et b non bon dans mon clavier au
comme j'aime beaucoup je voulais au
droit et au drame
puis comme j'aime bien les musiciens qui
jouent sur d'autres sections musique
parce qu'ils jouent pas comme celui qui
a ajouté le tas j'aime bien sa façon de
jouer aussi alex donc il est arrivé ce
pays devait statut des deux moitiés de
tourner parce qu'il y avait des
engagements aussi donc joseph et joseph
me suivent sur notre ami vous excuse moi
josé joseph tu sais pas je prédis fillon
doivent recteur qui doit qui est bon ou
c'est une inspiration pour moi très haut
certains se fout je le disais la même
foulée guillon et si le fou du roi
allez y avait toujours la difficulté à
faire le thème de notre pique nique
ah ouais donc on a passé une bonne heure
un bon bout de tournai où la plupart du
temps il n'y arrivait pas de suite au
début puis à rentrer quelqu'un de sexy
un souvenir qui se rappelle tellement
clairement fait que en fait si tu le
fais tout le monde est content car
conatus je le fais pas et a décidé que
tu le faisais mort à clipser licence
poétique se conforme pas rentrer et
j'écoutais j'avais je vais acheter le
pire à gabriel je me suis piqué l'album
puis y'a pas disney il n'y a pas de
cymbales sur son une pie ix
enfin moi je suis j'écoutais savez je
n'ai pas vu peut-être 18 ans c'est un
piège capote et surtout ce pilote ya pas
longtemps il ya cinq ou dix heures c'est
long 5e dont il parlait de cet album la
pizza ya plein d'erreurs tu es la face
c'est une erreur de penser que c'est des
choix
j'étais complètement déçu le sujet
j'aurais aimé mieux jamais de savoir se
souvient vtb plus est riche et non le
nombre d'albums qui ont été faits en
s'inspirant de data sont là et en guise
de salut effet domino
rien décidé l'effet papillon d'une
erreur de main donc alain cariou qui est
qui et qui avaient de la difficulté avec
son thème un jour on fait un spectacle
pour compagnie de distribution de films
un party de noël puis la baisse et par
alain kiki c'est alex qui est au clavier
puis guillon mais pas là non plus fait
cogniaux alex joseph mois by jo on le
fait à 4 et quand on a commencé quand on
est en balance de son on a commencé à
faire dans ce foot nique le thème italie
et on ne font ce que ce soir on s'est
tous regardés par huit partis à rire
allez je t'aime
il doit jouer d'affaires 10 fois plus
compliqué que ça mais c'était mouloud
est fantastique alain chanter avec eux
ils ont se font par un couple de
panthères ont beau aujourd'hui une
taille suis soumis mais si on me fait
toutes les harmonies
je suis quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
que j'admire beaucoup qui est avec toi
depuis longtemps bay et à se rêver mieux
a baissé au ballon avec macky juste pour
eux
par curiosité complète pour reprendre
faire suite à ton anecdotes sur peter
gabriel est ce qu'il ya des erreurs que
maintenant à mettons que que tu que tu
réalises chose que tu ferais
différemment sur un album culte comme
rêver mieux par exemple qui sont rendus
par est partie intégrale des chansons
mais que toi c'était une erreur non pour
reprendre un petit peu le bc 1 10
franchement non je puis le je dis pas
que je lis jamais pensé mais avec la
tête que j'ai aujourd'hui sur surtout
sachez comme je vous ai 10 30 oc c'est
ce que j'ai fait moi
oui on non je pense à un truc en
particulier je me suis plus quelle
chance ont arrêté le fond de le savoir
pour les besoins de la question mais il
ya souvent un jeu souvent que je prends
jamais les kicks piste alain quirion qui
venait faire le hyatt le du snu puis des
fois je trouve ça manque de goût je
trouve ça un peu bien comme ça aurait pu
être plus plus loose plus leur pipe lui
les d'backs pour parler encore français
est bien un jour quand j'ai travaillé
connais richard cyr sur les bensa pire
c'est qu'ils touchent au gabon oui merci
[Rires]
après ça on a fait ça permet de la maine
7 carmen le maine a été plus difficile à
faire parce que renaud charles ix
il est tombé malade gravement menacée
dominic champagne qui est venu le le
relever et et après ça dans un espèce de
briefing de postes briefing il m'avait
dit on avait remarqué certaines affaires
sur la musique sur la mise en scène y ce
qu'il y avait il y avait terminé en
disant garde ça marche il faut arrêter
les gens l'ont connu comme ça et on
aimait ça comme ça où ils ont pas aimé
ça comme ça mais c'est ça qui est arrivé
on n'y peut rien
pour la semaine pour la suite c'est
quand même pas des tragédies le tunnel
en juger taille des arbres malades
l'autre je pense que mon histoire était
mais il faut arrêter de s'en faire trop
mettre le tue pas arrêter de trop tout
tu regardes car il résulte une aire un
petit peu parce que ça un peu le garder
de ton gardien direct d'être comme ça à
coeur ce qui pose qu'à chaque fois aussi
tu es tu faire mieux mairal banques
aient besoin métier quelqu'un qui est
dit
on cherche une chanson puis chaque
chanson je fais ce post chanson le
cacher chez sa mère celle là c'est mieux
de s'en moquer non mais tu as fait tu
cherche tout le temps tu cherche
toujours la chanson s'arrêtera jamais
tant que tu as le goût de le faire je
pense pas que tu sa piste des concentrés
de que de penser qu'à ça c'est ma
meilleure j'ai fini parce que c'est trop
le fun aussi parce que c'est ça changera
crise mais rata meilleures chansons
d'aujourd'hui est peut-être plus et
peut-être meilleur ou plus proche que ta
meilleure chanson que tout se trouvait
que ça fluctue sa bouche et il sait que
les chansons que tu constates sont tes
meilleurs mets ton était plus fiable
plus aujourd'hui sonne aujourd'hui
urgent ils étaient plus de fun de jouer
en show par exemple où c'est eli lilly
et je ne prends de cartes et avec
intouchable et mortelle je trouve ça un
bon flair favori du puy sap a été un
succès commercial mais ce que j'appelle
des succès d'estimé que quand je t'ai
commence quand tu fais premier à mesure
du spectacle
tout le monde est contre moi puis mais
je vais pas jouer radio rares sont les
chansons du moins dans mon cas où est ce
que quand mettons c'est moi qui mettait
la musique puis que c'était chef au
saumon sur moi sur mon téléphone
rares sont les moments où est ce que
quand cette chanson le port les gens
écoutent la chanson ah oui ça c'est ce
que j'appelle sur le lait les fils théo
et to heaven wii très bonnes joues dans
un parti le monde de parler puis mon
écoute mais au chaabi mortels sait ce
que ça fait je suis content parce
qu'elle est juste là là riffs de guitare
c'est vraiment un truc c'est les broches
de boutiques boring boring boring il ya
une espèce de mouvement de roues à
tomber comme ça mais c'est quand même la
musique qui m'ont inspiré le texte
puis je me souviens que je travaillais
avec carl bastien
ça faisait longtemps qu on est en studio
pour rêver mieux
puis on était dans un cul de sac puis
jeudi à 15 ans et continue d'embaucher
j'en ai ma claque donc je suis parti à
la maison en voiture survenu en vélo
puis le vélo en fait sont eux ça a
dégagé des plaisirs et flux really
really l'apparence la plaisir ou fini et
je pense j'ai commencé le le texte après
ça et après ça
karl est venu mixer sa rue notre dame
tout près d'ici et on connaissait pas on
connaissait la musique est toute faite
la structure était le fait de manger
mille textes sur la structure je me
souviens qu'à l'aube à saint-thélo mon
frère
j'étais là et j'ai mis pour la première
fois le texte donc et peut-être un
troisième brise parce que j'ai toujours
trois prises
la première prise pour me trompe et la
deuxième pour consolider des gens qui
marchent la troisième je la fais comme
ça et là j'ai vu dans leur phase que ça
ça marchait est-ce que tu le sens pas
oui oui et qu'on le sent fort quand il
touche quelque chose de si tu quand on
sent qu'on les aime quand on sent que
quelque chose j'ai pas senti que ça
allait toucher tout le monde et je
sentis cuche de voiture c'est un tube
mais tu te dis ça c'est vraiment une
chance et donc toute la partie
instrumentale dedans c'était pas mon
initiative telle initiative de michel
bélanger qui à chaque fois qu'ils
quittaient le la tourner le mixed race
plus de musique plus de musique que
j'aime le plus
il manquerait passer la commande à
calais le jour-j et à l'eau tu devrais
faire plus de musique est calme nous on
est parti car le mix et il a mis plus de
musique plus d'effet plus de trucs
partie et on lit que le lendemain pour
capoter
vraiment mais pendant un été au complet
j'avais une copine qui habite en basse
ville de québec puis moi je descendais
tout les soirs aussi à travailler je
descendais la 3e avenue à québec avec
cette chanson le truc en sur les heures
où est ce qu il faisait noir piqué des
briques des étoiles en vélo un vélo
c'est sur un vélo ça marque vraiment ça
l'à beaucoup marqué ma môme on imagine
le non humain web
en partie instrumentale antunes chez
leur étoile et ouais des plantes se tuer
exact mais il ya une cohérence avec ce
que tu dis tantôt les critiques contre
un choix entre avait l'otsi fait qu'il y
ait vraiment oui c'est ça ma vraie vie
vraie vie c'est ces supports je vais
même mes journées ne sont posées je
pense pas au succès jamais jamais jamais
je pense parce que je pense pas ma phase
pense pas à la chance que j'ai de faire
des trous ce matin je crois que je suis
daniel benji c'est pourquoi j'étais en
train de laver les essais de daniel
bélanger
à chaque action secoue les on parle un
peu de tout mais nous c'est son nul à
l'occasion de la voix en avant primeur
qu'est ce qui a amené ce désir de faire
un album instrumental qui nous fait
littéralement voyager bello c'est parti
d'une espèce de une constatation un peu
froide
je n'ai de faire la musique du film de
luc picard qui s'appelait l'audition je
n'ai remporté un prix jutra
et puis je me tape
peut-être que je vais peut-être avoir
d'autres invitations pour la musique
d'affirmer je pensais que j'avais une
bonne job mais pauvre sa vie dont ils
ont tout entendu ce qu'il vaut
non ils ont tout entendu les erreurs que
moi je reconnais dans l'âtre piges
j'ai été démasqué un peu comme ça que je
me suis tu seras pas aussi mairie mais
c'est une impression ben si c'est
factuel que j'ai toujours pour ton et
crèches qui ait pu arriver
après ces quelques années plus tard jean
je pense et jean-françois grande et
l'acteur qui jouait dans crazy marc
andré marc andreu qui dit qu'ils avaient
noté que quand hier gagné un jury les
personnes qu'il a appris pendant très
très longtemps passé trop occupés mais
les gens pensent tétreault occuper trop
cher j'imagine nom et que le ca le tout
des partitions lancé il ya soixante où
il ya soit en non je pris goût d'avoir
je veux quelqu'un de vrai on est on est
dans un petit monde ici il pas vrai que
je joue je vais aller chercher daniel
bélanger ou mac un dribble ya peut-être
un truc comme ça qui est arrivé je veux
pas le même que moi que ce jeu qu'est
loin de mes doigts de film en film
finalement c'est jamais toi je m'en
plaignais pas juste que je puisse être
trop le travail faire de la musique de
film che c'est beaucoup de travail
en tout cas ça l'avait été techniquement
jeu
j'apprenais l'autre comment fonctionnez
travail à l'image puis mais le capi car
était tellement tellement fin que ça ça
adoucit seul travail et le jeu se met
juste je suis à me faire le jeu des
personnes mais des affaires de musiques
de films seront en fait je jauge bond
des ventes et des thèmes du générique du
début et c'est parti un peu comme ça
mais ça a évolué en cours de route sur
les premières trac que j'ai retrouvé les
premières pistes ouvertes pour une des
chansons c'est peut-être 2012-2013
effectivement je faisais sakutin j'ai vu
j'ai vu juliette partager sur son
instagram disait à ses chansons
deviennent sortir je l'entends depuis
cinq ans oui je me suis je faisais que
ça dépote
il ya longtemps puis est arrivé un
moment j'avais le choix le faire qu'en
plus ça a été juste le temps possible le
gmi une ou deux deux ministres mental
serait venu j'ai mis deux instrumental
sur l'échec ce matériel je suis mis
beaucoup de une sur paloma pas que sheen
espèces les je pense que les gens qui
apprécient mon travail son union
d'habitude d'instrumental avesnois de
pièces instrumentales a toujours été
lawn finalement trop existé et on vient
de parler de l'immortel simili insolente
et donc je vais je me faire un album est
un album de films donc fait studieux
plutôt que romain vita mais de la
musique se veut sur des films j'ai
invité des réalisateurs peut-être un
jour amenés à faire un film sur ma
musique en ré mais c'était une boutade
finalement peut-être que ça se pourrait
mais genre de choses sur chacun des
films ce serait vraiment intéressant et
genre de choses
découpez musique mais aussi carrément
d'instrumentation pdd de la musique qui
rappelle nous prenez par exemple plus
évident pour ces je pense le plus connu
de d2 de ceux qui font la musique de
film il y en a d'autres comme l'îlot
chiffré ni qui faisait des espèces de 10
films policy law chiffres insee celui
qui a lieu chaque croire celui que je
peux dire de connerie et qui aimante il
qu'écrit le thème de mission impossible
maggie puis fac j'ai tout pris mes
influences d'ambiance dans le fond
comment j'étais quand j'avais 12 ans que
j'entends des missions impossibles à tv
donc c'est un peu l'interprétation de
deux de ses ambiances intérieures le que
j'ai depuis toujours de du plaisir que
j'ai gîte rhdp fort sur des musiques de
films avec ennio morricone y est je trie
pas encore j'aime découvrir
je savais pas que je le connaissais mais
je le connaissais et où vous le
connaissez aussi c'est bernard herrmann
c'est celui qui fait la file d'hitchcock
hitchcock
ces taxes sont derniers donc j'ai
toujours aimé sa musique évidemment
qu'on aime ça et qu il ya ça laisse
personne indifférent c'est capoter
d'arrivée suisse et des compositeurs qui
a qui connaissent tous l'air ils
connaissent la nature des instruments de
musique qui savent quoi sortir de quatre
violons ensemble que ça devienne
complètement paniqué donc ils
connaissent andrea perfection le comment
rendre une émotion avec avec par
l'instrumentation puis par la remit
jamais fait et ne jamais bypass et
l'image toujours être au service de
l'image mais a été fait à sept jours du
chou ou égales pour que ça fasse que ça
porte chance on fout pas que le cinéma
lui c'est la musique qui m'ont influencé
plus que les images en même temps le
cinéma aussi votre jour tu te rappelles
kate est allée avec telle fille shiloh
baisse atteint je fais partie de ta vie
aussi sa compagne mais c'est quoi ton
expérience qu'entrevue tel film sera
dans la rue de tavi l'avait quittée
depuis les faits marquants moins qu'à
three marqué le têt et lectures à l'ispo
they can
je te demande pas qu'est ce qui était
mis dans le film de sécurité
complètement engourdis par le film péter
un étal fontenoy ce qui fait qu'un film
est marquant souvent c'est la musique
on dirait que fauqué lead vocal les deux
les scènes marquantes faut qu'un petit
je pense justement pour regarder
l'exemple de morricone et tu penses à de
good the bad and the ugly puis la scène
par cynthia l'ouest qui coopèrent avec
cette chance cette scène le sang la
musique qui devenu caisse ma plus grande
que le film
ouais ça serait pas la même chose de ses
pieds nus me retourner avec son joli on
est sinde des rares occasions où est ce
que justement la musique qui était
souvent composer avant parce qu'on
faisait tellement confiance en son
composteur
ils changent et le montage des fois
parce que c'était tout à fait qu'ils
sont même sur le set et écouter la
musique était déjà composé pour se
mettre dans l'ambiance est vraiment oui
tout à fait l'allemand la musique
précédé les l'image de ce qu'ils
quittent kirop ce qui peut-être les
copeaux de chambly mai mais ces sommes
étaient des films quand même comme ça on
était la liste de schindler c'est allez
vous ah bon ouais ça vaille vous ne
seriez subi certains oui jusqu'à ses
baskets aux politiques voyez le film
c'est après leur voyage
[Rires]
je vais te renvoyer tous cas je pense la
paternité tromper de cassettes que c'est
capoté parce que c'est utile c'est 100
de moroni de sergio leone il n'y avait
pas la musique et puis des fois tu
touche pendant qu'ils disent je tente de
me dit patrick que non peut-être que la
musique l'image est tellement fort puis
que si tu mets juste quelque chose qui
se rapproche de l'émotion peut-être tout
comme si je sais pas tout explose en
même temps mais c'est tout des trucs
très très fort aussi
et on sait peut-être que l'image
extrêmement forte la musique est
extrêmement puissante aussi pantin de
bois de 200 g je suis dans des films ou
est ce que justement l'équation telle
addition aux délits majak la musique
tiff est belle aussi
c'est benneteau mélodramatique le fac
mais sa tartine au début puis la
dernière étape sanitaire sa personne
exact jveux film évidemment pas ce que
je faisais en musique de luc picard le
petit mais regardez tous les films dont
il y avait un film qui me plaisait
beaucoup je m'en souviens pas le film
récent puis il ya tellement pas de
musique quand la musique arrive ça peut
très fort ce site si com dispose de
techniques aussi cinématographique et je
vois dire de bêtises mais je pense que
potes il n'y a pas de musique non c'est
dans ces films ça se passe et ce qui est
pas ce qui est vraiment pas être non
plus et laisse lens c'est un style tout
aussi précaire monseur enfin et
réalisateur qu'il son nouveau film
l'homme et ont parfois qui a acheté les
droits faisait acheter pour son as ils
se sont vraiment pressé d'aller se jeter
plein dans son flash sur le web
oui il faut tu as toi jusqu'à
satisfaction et joue à l'instar de la
latence à blanc c'est ça oui oui oui il
joue je viens d'avoir accepté oui oui
c'est sa facture pour ceux qui étaient
déçus que les projets à son chauffeur
avait un attachement pas on parle tantôt
de l'espèce de jeu change de sujet
doublement le meti le changement de
paysage culturel puis de tous ceux
est-ce que tout y tient à l'affût de
béton ce qui sort ce qui ce fait les
niveaux d'artistes ou québec oui oui
mais forcément j'en perds je cherche je
parle c'est tout c'est le tenir le fil
complet où je pense pas que je pense
c'est le cas de ben zhang chi mais ça
tout à coup tintin à la base où êtres
qui tu allumes tout mettant des nouveaux
artistes préférés mais tant qu'il aura
volé
oui ben phu qui sans connaître tout ce
qu'il fait j'aime bien piano riquet -
témoin qui moins nouvelle ouais je me
suis sa voix me touche parfaitement les
louanges
j'aime bien parce qu'il ya un côté jazz
à côté moi j'aime que ça la musique
princes de ce bord là cette direction le
pour le reste et je vais pas m denoix
sur ce que j'aime
est ce qu'il ya un album et pop daniel
bélanger x ans avait passé en dessous
qui tue album à quand la bagarre mais
l'idée c'est de sa dette une grenouille
ou une vache et de rester vague si je
t'aime grenouille je peux pas me prendre
pour quelque chose que je suis pour le
rap et pour ma culture non
donc si je décide finalement que je
m'entoure aide aux gens qu'ils font sur
les gens qui font ça pour faire d'eux
pour faire de bêtises pour faire
n'importe quoi ici sérieux si j'ai le
goût de le faire je sais chic de ville
c'est pas le projet le plus excès pour b
devant puis je suis au début miles en
ont annoncé que j'ai envie de passer
comme quoi j'ai envie de faire ça c'est
vrai que le défi d'assumer toujours ce
qu'on aie aie aie pis pour moi ça a été
je fais de l'uni sic en tout cas j'en ai
fait une scic le truc c'est jamais de te
battre contre le poids sans vote et
c'est quoi ton pause pour voir le fait
toujours face là où doit toujours faire
face à la roue
citons poil et ça marche copeaux et on
dirait que c'est comme ça en musique
pour moi c'est vrai canon géant 800
vauvert lemay sus aïe aïe ouille
mais après ça j'y vais lobé ce test
c'était chic de ville fac avec chic de
ville j'ai eu des lits projet de les
faire des copains âge ville qui ont
profité pour installer abbey road un
jour dans un autre projet puisage
aimerait se retourner à beyrouth pour
mon propre affaire finalement quand
j'appuie stomacale marche qui séné toile
est donc là plusieurs moyens d'aller à
peut-être des fois juste avec d'autres
réalisateurs des sessions qui sont
souples et à deux autres leaders
enfin qu'ils mais je pourrais je
pencherai plus à l'aise à le faire en
âge ville puis fac les jambes c'est cool
je vais prendre l'avion je vois là
nashville première fois nashville ont la
libye doit être visitée plein du studio
on jubile ocean ou chinois zhu élevé le
studio ici ou sohu et donc j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça on enregistrait lundi
dimanche soir le lundi gras aux journées
de deux cordes puis le mardi matin on
est allés visiter que je prenais l'avion
demande après midi je suis venu faire
une petite vite mais ça c'est le font
ici c'est ce que je trouve désolant pour
moi aujourd'hui ans avec la pandémie tic
sujet il faut que je devrais
l'enregistrer ailleurs rallye composé
ailleurs juste pour voir comment les
merengues l'annulation juste aller à
l'essentiel il ya pas longtemps puis je
te la deuxième fois mais le cndd vraie
foi j'ai adoré d'assange rejet de tout
ce que le monde à east de saint louis
missouri
est ce que ça va falloir se retenait va
falloir faire autre chose de frais levés
j'ai beau jeu sur les compositions
bordelaises tout est passé d'un beckham
mais quand même
moi j'ai une question est temps que moi
quelqu'un qui sait vraiment beaucoup
attaché à plusieurs et et de textes qui
souvent sont extrêmement personnel du
moins qui apparaissent très personnel
est-ce que met-on mettons comprend une
chanson comme cruel parce que c'est une
chanson qui somme toute assez difficile
ou du moins qui sait écouter et leur
grande émotion quand même au respect des
chroniques que - est-ce que c'est
difficile quand mettons tu arrives en
chantant en spectacle avec ses textes
est ce que tu es encore paie aujourd'hui
le mais quand tu le tunnel de l'écrire
tunnel à composer est ce que tu t'es
encore trop proche de sitex lui qui sont
tristes et mélancoliques pour pouvoir
apprécier qui en mettant le riff de
guitare plus haute du monde m'en
foutisme est à moitié à crier karaoké
sur quelque chose qui au final est trop
personnelle phi phi témoin mettons
l'exemple parfait que j'ai pour ce je
suis allé voir jean leloup puis il se
met à jouer je joue de la guitare t-il
un texte sur la dépression qui va
extrêmement déçu
puis un gars qui montait sur le state
puis c'est mia albrand cette même pluie
le juste à regarder ça vous regarde
d'encore ici le poignet cette chanson-là
de se faire déranger comme ce parti
qu'un qui comprend pas du tout fait
juste ce qui est un peu et sensible qui
fait jusqu'à moi je joue je n'ai pas les
paroles tiendra le refrain oui je sais
pas si ma question fait chanceler mais
ce qu'on dit mais ce que c'est quelque
chose qui soit aux véhicules ti
d'affaires est là cette chanson-là
joujou verse mon sentiment
puis vous rock et ça c'est curieux parce
qu' un coup que ses écrits audrey que
c'est c'est écrit donc là on en faire
une chanson et la caméra le jeu sort me
suis fait prendre dans ce plaisir l'aude
était prêté mes chansons moi je voulais
faire des chansons je voulais faire de
la scène
je voulais chanter mais jamais j'ai
pensé que je me développerait en tant
qu'interprète
j'interprète jamais les chansons ou à
peu près des autres et là je me suis
pris et j'ai eu du plaisir à interpréter
mes chansons les vivent les interpréter
comme quoi pas donc presque une mise en
scène ne capte une souci d'un de
présentation vivre ta chanson we est ma
chanson je les véhicules je les écris 2
et c'est correct chute en jeu c'est
carré gée correct ma chanson il ya une
chanson que je me suis pincé une fois je
vais raconter mais donc comme par
exemple cruel benjamin le maintenant
cruel c'est mon texte
c'est ma chanson et j'ai du plaisir à
leur travail
en fait puis de la présenter puis de la
présentation mieux puisqu'elle a dit que
ce soit que ce soit crédible il
plausible il donc je ne sais pas que je
et que j'assume pas ce que j'ai écrit
mais c'est fait donc ce que j'avais à
vie avec la chanson je les véhicules
privés en la composent un puck
il a apprécié le reste sa partie il faut
que je me retire et que ce soit ok ça
appartient au monde appartient au monde
qui la reçoit junte et refaire un peu il
est arrivé une fois donc que j'ai
commencé dit tout sans rien dire mais
comme c'est un truc d'humeur la chanson
les spectacles ggg je me fait pincer en
commençant la chanson je rentre beaucoup
de ma chanson et jenson qui cachent
quand je me mets à penser à des affaires
qui m'ont inspiré cette chanson là je
fais jamais ça sérieux j'essaie de me
détacher et de profs faire du show avec
mes émotions je veux juste que les gens
entendent ma chanson qui la prennent
pour eux et le schéma fait
je vais fait vraiment penser du tangage
et le jeu vient moto en gare et là je la
difficulté à chanter ma chanson et je
veux pas enfin ce je pourrais je veux
pas faire un show je sais pas je crois
pas que ce soit le sait que rien dire
mais je crois pas que ce soit l'imam en
deux phases fallait que je le fasse
fouchy façon privée et puis cette
chanson l'heure c'est sûr je me suis
inspiré des trucs assez intense mais je
me suis fait prendre au jeu de chanter
une chanson et puis de d'avoir de l'amdi
plus je me souviens ai dit il faut je la
fais n'est ce donc pense plus que tu y
réfléchis pu faire texte ça y est
et après ça je me suis dis je je je je
vais plus jamais revivre ça va vite ça
parce que c'est pas c'est pas ma manière
de travailler et c'est parce que c'est
trop dur pour toi ou parce que tout soit
30 par l'histoire tout simplement d'être
tu lis tu chantes lettres sur mon dieu
pauvre gars qui vit seul but d'être sa
maîtrise sentiment que t'es pas en train
de donner le meilleur show de secours
est donnée ou alors que 8,8 10,6 jeu
pour boya chaque sous le sens où être au
top là bas il ya un peu de ça mais ça il
faut que ce soit photon interprétation
soit crédible mais juste pas vrai que je
vais je vais me répandre comme ça devant
hollande je trouve pas ça cool pour les
gens qui écoutent mieux en attaque très
près de voir le chanteur boyer sur sa
chanson mais moi c'est quand je vois un
show côte ça arrive ça arrive mais comme
tu dis faudrait pas que j'en fasse une
habitude que la larme soit planifiée de
répondre sérieusement de kirby mais en
même temps moi je mets transpose du
point de vue du public de
de vivre ce moment là où est-ce que
bélanger vulnérable sur la scène c'est
quand même moi je crois pas que je crois
pas j'ai l'air sans coeur tous les
journaux dont j'utilise unification et
en même temps je pourrais très bien
choisir de pleurer mais dans un truc de
d'interprétation - une approche
d'interprétation perroquet jeu je le
sais je jure à la fin nous entre la ddt
l'avant-dernier samedi
peut-être que je pourrai prendre cette
option le peut-elle je le ferai mais ça
serait très concret je le contrôle est
un peu bête là mais ce soit un choix
mais là je me suis dans l'impression des
deux d'en faire trop le loup est tombé
dans la cuisine mais pudique qui comme
chez céline comme vous dites et je
connais que je souhaitais la larme
facile mais si ça fait part de sa mise
en scène la larme à l'alarmé pas une
fille mais peut-être pas mais il y à
sortir pour toi on parlait de dix parler
des textes puis ils ont dit qu'en
écoutant ton oeuvre d'outils comme les
grands thèmes qui ressortent le team et
on l'a la folie est souvent cité mais
ton le type plusieurs types de thoune
aussi présents la solitude aussi
ouais je sais mon grand thème grands
thèmes pense que oui quand je quand j'y
repense je souhaite finir tout
l'impression que met-on ondrais qu'à la
lumière de 2020 ça prend tout un nouveau
sens assez bien curieux la solitude en
ce moment c'est bien curieux parce que
dans un spoutnik que jamais aussi bien
vieilli qsssl et oui tout à fait mais ça
y est
c'est gênant d'être contente pas de
vendre
non non non mais je remarque l'étude on
peut la voir venir depuis longtemps
ouais je suis pas devin mais il fait
déjà neuf il ya l'air du temps c'est
fait moi je suis disponible à augusta ce
moment je sens léger c'est de sentir qu
est ce qui se passe plus je compose moi
que je prends mon café dans un café
conversation petit coin laval mille et
une vagues et une peur à ce moment de
quelque chose que j'essaie d'interpréter
leur destin reste un grand rêve le jeu
réussit pas la plupart du temps mais y
arrive des fois où il ya des tonnes
comme l'échec du matériel et la toune la
fin de l'homme il y avait une vraie vibe
de l'air du temps là dessus puis toute
la l'échec du matériel mais c'est juste
c'était pas quelque chose de vrai là
dedans le fonds appuie puis j'ai pas un
an après le terrible crash de 2008 ch je
l'avais pas prévu je pense pas que je
sais juste que dans l'air du temps ça se
pouvait on sentait que ça pouvait
arriver imminente
on vit j'arrivais pas moins nommer les
choses j'aurais mais je leur ai jamais
pu prévoir un cachemire nous y fait ce
qui en ce moment se laisse imprégner
aussi de l'art du temps pour un prochain
album à paroles qui viendra oui mais pas
peur que ce soit un direct je pourrais
pas parler carrément de la pandémie
monte les gens vont en avoir jusqu'à
leur facture alors tu entres pas tant
que ça de triper sur une chanson qui en
parle
je respecte ce fut mon truc léger
claquage mardi au plus à risque avec sa
puce pourrait que j'avais plus envie
d'entendre ce discours est directement
c'est comme elle
les attaques du 11 septembre
c'est surtout sa peau notre pays mais je
remarque que chez ceux de tunis ap un
long bout avec les artistes
et après tout ce qui est arrivé les
écrits 27,5 en prêt ou dix ans après que
ça c'est mieux
la guerre du vietnam musique rock rageur
fotia pour réfléchir
le grand défi la chanson en ce qui me
concerne c'est d'être tout petit tout
petit tout petit puis d'essayer de viser
la communication avec c'est d'essayer de
de décrire d'obtenir d'établir un
contact avec quelqu'un il c'est pour ça
que la solitude ce thème chez moi parce
que c'est souvent tout garni qui dit ce
qu'est ce qui nous relie à dieu celle
incommunicable c'est ce qu'ont ce qui
tue qu'on était capable de communiquer à
qui que ce soit à ya dieu lui une
compresse exactement et
l'incommunicabilité c'est pour moi c'est
une source d'inspiration beaucoup tous
les détours qu'on fait procès
communiquer quelque chose contre l'autre
comprend pas et pour moi c'est fascinant
moi ça me saoule je me sors mais là
dessus puis la musique est finalement en
étant un remède
cette solitude là dessus mais pas
seulement jouer c'est le jouet de cette
joie de se joue à deux mains du monde
mais peut-être c'est vrai que on sait
pas trop pourquoi on aime chansons plus
qu'une autre
ça vient chercher des choses qu'on
épargne intellectualiser il faut que ça
ça fait du bien oublie ce fait du bien
gratis entendu ça tu es tombé dessus qui
était censé blessure j'ai par rapport à
la celle études mettant sur la question
on pourra maintenant mais ce qui est
ce qu'est daniel bélanger malgré tout
les succès pas mal malgré la halle elle
justement la carrière la vie la famille
tout est ce que des mélanges et souffre
de ce différend b je le dire comme tout
le monde je pense qu'il alla fine au
début et à la fin on est seul enfin que
ça départ commence quand les gars de se
distraire de ce genre je n'ai pas décidé
que ça allait être un thème principal
dans ce que je fais mais si c'est ce qui
m'inspire fait que j'ai oublié ta
question s'il souffrait de solitude
oui comme tout le monde ouais aussi
souvent aussi plus ouvert que tu mens
biaye pitt
tu peux te sentir tout seul par une
foule qui peut te sentir pas tout seul
tout seul
il ya beau y ait beaucoup de température
dans beaucoup tonalité de solitude
dernière question avant conclut salée
pour entreprendre ajournée au complet
mais je me sentirai trop content pour
profiter au maximum stack on inclure la
piscine et moti choc
ce que est ce que quelqu'un qui
composent ma question est temps de vol
est ce que quand il compose une chanson
décrit parole est-ce que les paroles des
fois viennent en premier avant la
musique ou jamais or presque jamais si
jamais gg je chante en yahoo qu'on
appelle donc des sonorités anglophone y
enseigne fois que j'ai tout mon pilotage
tout mon flaumont mais aucune parole au
sud aucune parole et puis là-bas je fais
de la peinture à numéros dans le son
sujet
et curieusement à chaque fois si je m'en
tiens seulement à mon phrasé qu'un
chante pas quand n'importe quoi ça
marche pas donc il faut que je m'inspire
du phrasé presseur faut que je le fasse
comme moi je capable de le faire
la mélodie et le tout à coup ça ça se
mérite
incarnez ça ça devient moi ou ce que je
veux faire fait que mais ça me cause
beaucoup de soucis
et c'est curieux parce que pierre
lapointe un jour me dit mon invité à
faire une musique sur un de ses textes
fhd oui
pierre moi juge toujours à l'inversé à
qui m'envoient le texte ça a été rapide
par la composent et j'ai envoyé ils
étaient super contents pelenise à 11 200
m 1 beaucoup moins compliqué d'écrire un
texte puis tu fais la musique issue donc
lundi matin commence à écrire des textes
finalement ça a foiré baradji n'est pas
capable comme ça que ça marche comme ça
ce que change pas garde des sabots
gamine tu m'aides erding chaussée de
sabots qu'il faut me souviens de mes
victoires le avec tant de gens pensent
que quelques postes et quelles chansons
dont tu parles d'une sortie oui oui sur
son avant dernier j'en ai une autre sur
son dernier
je t'écris cette chanson a oui comme une
lettre la nuit ils allaient 3 6 1 c'est
beau mais son texte si son texte et
rythme et je t'écris cette chanson comme
une lettre ça veut dire de tête que tu
liras peut-être effet ce musical scie
musicale mais ça me surprend quand même
ses méthodes de travail parce que c'est
les mots dans la musique dès bélanger
sont pas justes sont pas que ce soit
sont pas que ce soit on peut juste le
pour être un véhicule d'un autre côté
c'est teddy prat à part peas et des
poèmes
ceci dit vion ayons atteint hier soir
mais moi je je je prête un pointu est un
paradis vraiment et donc ça comme ça sa
vie parce que souvent je pourrais lire
baudet des chansons où je répète par
exemple quitter mais le quand tu lis
stress et répétitif je suis pas certain
que ça puisse vivre tout seul alors que
ben si il y en a donc peut-être que oui
mais met donc c'est je suis un parolier
ascendant paillettes mais je pense qu'à
la fin je jetais un parolier donc pas
relier le poète oui s'en fait pas avec
la musique sa musique et dans son texte
est pour ça que c'est dur de mettre en
musique des dépôts est ce la musique est
dans la musique et dans le poème comme
si tu rajoutes et une autre musique
je pense
donc oui combien j'ai eu le droit à une
autre question aussi mais pas question
de commencer titre à l'album sorti tu
avais trois temples te fait plusieurs
jobs avant puis je sais qu'il ne séduit
blues était préposé aux bénéficiaires
est-ce que c'est assez haché ce titre
est extrait ce que est ce que de voir ce
qui se passait là dedans dit il il est
justement d'aider les personnes plus
vulnérables tels allemand dans la
solitude justement ce que ces nus de
chercher viscéralement la doit surtout
qu'il a vu de l'intérieur
oui c'est un milieu j'ai trouvé très
difficile malgré je les fais longtemps
je fait qu est à peu près 4 4 ou 5 assez
pour voir plus expérimentés tout pas mal
tout et ce qui me revenaient quand c'est
arrivé c'était le c'était l'ambiance
l'ambiance une aile tribune corps et
leur pilote
démasqué jusqu'aux oreilles pilotes
étaient et gantés pelles parce que les
relations qu'ont avec les libye nice
hier c'est des relations de deux voisins
on est en bon voisinage
il faut les voir madame un pouf je pense
à ceux ouverts d'où elle mais finit par
duco les habitudes de chacun puisque
c'est très mois l'époque où je
travaillais
j'ai été formé par des des femmes
extraordinaires de la génération de ma
mère ou des femmes très impliqué très
affectueuse mais très professionnel et
donc recréé
une atmosphère chaleureuse familiale je
me souviens des dames
je travaillais deux soirs plus obèses
test s'était dit doit y annoncer des
femmes qui se faisait à 25 ans qui
faisait ce lundi je commence à
travailler le don de bien daniel on va
aller ouvrir lilly je veux ouvrir
l'élite donc l aparté et puis avant vers
après tu subis pendant qu'il est encore
en train de manger à leur futur lieu
nous on n'ouvrait lily donc ont préparé
le coucher ça des trucs comme ça des
trucs comme je me souviens jour on
cherche et pauline une préposée aux
bills sienne moi j'avais 20 ans elle
avait c'était une vieille de 42 et on
cherchait pauline partout et on l'a
retrouvé couché avec une bénéficiaire
pour l'endormir dans l'après midi mais à
s'est fait pincer endormi avec éclat va
réveiller pauline pas ce qu'il faut
faire mais s'était jamais c'est toujours
dans l'ambiance de gt je me trouve
chanceux je pense à poney de charlebois
jeunes et une boucherie n'espérons cdc
j'ai été formé par des bonnes par des
bonnes femmes
le moussem de droit oui mais c'était
chaleureux se bat il y avait une
ambiance de chaleur parce qu'on avait le
temps d'être chaleureux pour l'état
puisque leur proposer et
je me souviens bon le jeu faisait
mettons un cat à minuit vers 8 heures
une mineure tout le monde te coucher et
l'on était on regarde la tv on se
faisait des toros on était chez pas on
était deux préposés puis la levée pas
croire que j'ai donc master compétents
les personnes qui endurent qu'un prévaut
au regard de tv puis qu'attendent les
clash foot fille a pas le temps fait que
c'est ça que sa mort a mené puis bon ben
évidemment ma belle-mère avaient été
amenés en ch et celle des j'ai vu
l'ambiance puis le détachement de
souvent des préposés parce qu'ils sont
sont dans des agents dans une folle
dingue qu'on ait personne peut-être je
parle à travers mon chapeau y
mais moi mon expérience c'était vraiment
du monde très détaché très détaché pour
des raisons bien humaine c'est un métier
dur puisque tu peux pas te prendre au
pied de la lettre tu vas mourir de
chagrin fait qu'il faut qu'ils gardent
une petite carapace mais là en plus bas
sont moins gt gt gt payer pour parler
d'argent mais mettons à l'époque il
savait me mettais à 3,25 j'étais payé on
dit quelque chose
saint ouen factice tu es comme trois
fois le salaire minimum est aujourd'hui
peu sont pas payés pour ça qu'il
commence peut-être à 30 dollars
mais c'est ça que ça veut c'est ça que
ça vaut c'est à dire qu'il fait on le
fait pas pour l'argent mais si on on
sait si on se tue à quelque chose de
très très
dur et le préposé vote en voie de
disparition ça sera pas longue
comme il lillois exactions puis c'est ce
qui est cool comme j'avais 20 ans quand
j'ai appris à faire ce truc là il me
reste encore des affaires aujourd'hui ne
s'était pas que la fin que quand j'avais
mes filles étaient petites jalousies
relie juge des samis reste pleine nuit à
l'époque j'étais révoltée de travailler
leur jeu est injuste
j'étais en mode y étaient obligés puis
c'était mon seul moyen de faire un petit
peu plus d'argent que de salaire minimum
qui mettait du puisque j'étais un drop
et je testais c'était assez injuste je
le faisais mais j'avais j'avais du coeur
à l'ouvragé quand même puis je partais
je me protège et aussi de faire ce de
d'être je me protégeais de la dureté de
ce travail là on est en rivalité bien je
devrais faire autre chose
puis aujourd'hui je suis juge à part le
fait que je me trouve un peu jeune pour
avoir fait ça à 20 heures je trouve que
c'est un peu jeune pour voir des
horreurs vraiment d horreur des horreurs
qu'ils sont bien naturelles ou qui
viennent avec eux qui viennent avec la
vie je suis content de l'avoir fait se
contenter des gens plus que ma mère
l'ait fait qu'eads et des femmes puis
des sommes plus vieux que moi qui m'a
donné des valeurs de respect de soi plus
morale de ce que je dis là mais ça que
ça mais ça m'est resté tout les skis
monde je ne savais pas qu'ils me
donnaient en plus du jeu de paume plus
sympathique collège à l'époque je
faisais même ma petite affaire
masi et à ses manques pour eux qu à ses
yeux verts sont assez d'empathie jamais
assez les jeunes leur donner des trucs
qu'ils savaient pas qu'ils me les games
et qui mime les montrer quand même fait
que la teinte et la personne puis donc
prêtes à miser aussi déçoit oui la folie
en cas de ces corps humain
ça vient de là quand je travaillais en
sachet se le dise le très peu à la mode
mais je me suis en auront un
on se préparait à savoir un be nice hier
qu'elle est qu'ils étaient atteints de
la maladie de l'alzheimer puis ils nous
disaient les fermiers ont dit bon on va
recevoir quelqu'un aujourd'hui c'est
très spécial je peux aussi vous avez
entendu parler de la maladie de
l'alzheimer mais il est très jeune ya 5
61 ans donc c'est plus de là on appelle
plutôt de la lémance on appelle cela
l'alzheimer pilote voit arriver le
monsieur qui sait pas où est ce qu'ils
pour nom piller comme j'ai pas le
situent les un corridor il va marcher
jusqu'au mur puis au mur hirate ferait
pas il fera pas demi tour et j'avais je
m'entends tu parlais je pense qu'il le
centre existe il avait fait dans l'est
ils ont fait je pense qu'il existe
encore un centre d'accueil pour la
maladie de l'alzheimer ou il ya pas de
spotify nous irons donc les rondes ils
font dans le fond ils font du jeudi
loupe les tours ce qui est très très
très bien basique mais très bien absurde
mais parfait mais ça sort 3 voilà ben
merci infiniment bienvenu ici puis de
répertoire à nous c'est un réel les
organiser déjà entendu je vous aime mais
parce que déjà garni je voulais je veux
aller noble ce support merci beaucoup
merci à vous deux c'était vraiment un
chouette drame un merci beaucoup